bonjour à tous merci pour votre fidélité
vous le savez Public Sénat se mobilise
pour vous faire suivre en intégralité
les auditions de la commission des Lois
du Sénat sur le mariage pour tous les
sénateurs procède à différentes
auditions pour préparer l'examen du
projet de loi ouvrant le mariage aux
personnes de même
ce matin ils entendent des personnalités
qualifiées dans le domaine de la
philosophie audition que je vous propose
de suivre tout de
suite donc ce matin nous avons deux deux
parties dans nos auditions dans une
première partie nous entendons des
associations et des organismes
compétents en matière d'adoption je vous
rappelle que la semaine prochaine nous
entendrons le le conseil supériur de
l'adoption je crois que ça s'appelle
comme ça et ensuite nous entendrons deux
philosophes monsieur Collin et Madame
magazenski voilà donc donc là nous avons
1h30 jusqu'à 10h30 et je donnerai
successivement la parole aux
associations qui sont ici présentes pour
un exposé liminire de pas plus de 10
minutes chacune sinon bon ça sera peut
un peu afin que les sénatrices qui sont
là déjà et rapporteurs et ceux qui
viendront puissent vous poser des
questions donc nous avons ici la
Fédération française des organismes
autorisés pour l'adoption qui réunit des
organismes habilités pour C
intermédiaires tant pour les
associations pour les adoptions
nationale qu'internationale et je
remercie sa présidente madame
marieclaude Friot d'être venue à notre
rendez-vous ce matin ensuite nous avons
trois
associations compétentes en matière
d'adoption le mouvement pour l'adoption
sans frontièr avec son président
Monsieur lasser
ensuite l'association alors je sais pas
monsieur lasser si vous vous appelez
Éric ou Marc Marc bon voilà alors Éric
donc Marc lasser parce que hier nous
avons eu un comme ça pour se détendre un
peu le matin nous avons entendu des
psychanalystes alors les psychanalystes
c'est pire que le monde de l'adoption je
suppose et donc nous avions un
psychanalyste on avait le prénom était
pas le bon prénom voilà il s'appelle
Daniel on avait mis Jean Daniel et donc
ça lu a posé un vrai problème
psychanalytique pendant 10 minutes voilà
donc c'est Marc
laasser ensuite nous avons l'association
enfants et famille d'adoption avec
Madame natthalie Paran qui est sa
présidente et la voix d' adoptée par
Madame Cécile février
qui va vraisemblablement arriver plus
tard car nous l'avons contacté que hier
je crois ou avanthier je ne sais plus on
a eu un peu de retard dans ce contact
mais si elle arrive elle prendra place
et elle voilà et puis nous avons des
vice-présidentes ou des membres du
conseiladministration des association
qui sont ici mesdames je m'excuse parce
que là c'est un peu compliqué mais si
vous voulez répondre à des questions qui
seront posées ensuite bien entendu vous
aurez la parole donc sans plus tarder
madame Rio je vous laisse la
parole euh là je crois voilà
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur alors excusez-moi juste un
mot puisque vous dit monsieur le
Président je dois excuser le président
de la commission des lois Monsieur
Jean-Pierre chur qui d'habitude préside
ses auditions puisque ce sont des
auditions de l'ensemble de la commission
mais qui ce matin est vous savez à la
conférence du consensus organisée par
Madame laarde des saau sur la récidive
et cetera et donc il il sera pas
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie au nom de la
Fédération français des organismes
autorisés pour l'adoption la
ffoa d'avoir bien voulu nous recevoir et
d'apporter une écoute attentive aux
acteurs de l'adoption que sont les
organismes autorisés pour
l'adoption la Fédération française des
organismes autorisés pour l'adoption
regroupe 26 organismes autorisé pour
l'adoption que nous nommerons maintenant
oa pour plus de simplicité soit plus de
la moitié des organismes privés
d'adoption les oa sont des opérateurs
privés qui assurent une mission de
service public comme intermédiaire
qualifié pour l'adoption de mineurs
résidant en France ou à
l'étranger la ffoa interlocuteur des
pouvoirs publics est membre du Conseil
supérieur de l'adoption le CSA et de
l'Agence française pour l'adoption LAFA
qui est l'opérateur
public les OAS de laffoa disposent d'une
expertise incontestable en matière
d'adoption expertise d à l'ancienneté
des OAS les plus récents OAS de la
Fédération ayant 20 ans d'ancienneté
cette ancienneté a permis d'accompagner
à long terme des postulants à l'adoption
des familles adoptives très diverse des
enfants adoptés devenus adolescents puis
adultes la FO dispose également d'une
expertise du nombre d'enfants accueillis
53 % des enfants adoptés par
l'intermédiaire des opérateurs privés le
son par les OAS de la
Fédération dans le contexte médiatique
qui entoure le projet de loi mariage
pour tous ce côtoie et sans chevêtre
plusieurs notions homophobie sexualité
et
homoparentalité les membres des oa
s'accordent sur le respect de la liberté
de toute personne à aimer une personne
de même sexe ou de sexe opposé il
n'appartient pas aux membres de la ffoa
de prendre position pour ou contre le
mariage des couples de personnes de
Me l'ouverture de l'adoption à ces
couples est par contre pour nous source
de
questionnement
l'homoparentalité fait déjà partie du
cadre de l'adoption célibataire qui
adopte ou célibataire qui ont un
conjoint de même sexe conjoint qui
n'apparaît pas dans les procédures
d'adoption il nous a donc déjà été donné
de réfléchir à
l'homoparentalité la ffoa souhaite
aborter son concours et sa réflexion
sans mettre en doute les capacités
affectives éducatives des couples de
même sexe
la nécessité d'un encadrement juridique
de leur union la nécessité d'apporter
une sécurité juridique aux enfants du
conjoint l'enfant adopté est à la fois
comme les autres et porteur de
différence il est aussi porteur d'un
passé dans le débat passionnel d'où
l'ouverture de l'adoption au coupe de
personnes de même sexe les membres de la
ffoa ont orienté leur réflexion sur
trois des axes de leur charte éthique à
savoir la responsabilité des OAS à
l'égard des
enfants la responsabilité des OAS à
l'égard des candidats à l'adoption et la
responsabilité des OAS à l'égard des
pays
d'origine à l'égard des candidats à
l'adoption le mariage pour tous donneura
le droit d'engager des démarches en vue
d'adoption la loi obligera à examiner
sans discrimination les demandes de
candidatur des couples de personnes de
même sexe s répondent aux conditions
requises les responsables d'A n'ignor
pas la douleur de tous les couples
confrontés à l'infertilité et à leur
profond désir de fonder une
famille cependant force de constater que
dans le contexte actuel et àenir de
l'adoption l'aboutissement de tout
projet d'adoption est
incertain l'agrément dé livvré aux
adoptants n'a pas pour corollaire
l'arrivée d'un
enfant en
1569 adoptions internationales ont été
enregistrées pour environ 24000
candidats en
attente le risque de nonaboudissement
des demandes de couplees de personnes de
même sexe est donc
important ces couples auront-ils de
réelles possibilité de construction de
famille par filiation
adoptive dans le cadre de l'adoption
nationale les OAS qui accompagnent les
femmes désirant confier leur enfant à
l'adoption s'attache à respecter le
souhait de ses mères combien de femmes
souhaiteront effectivement confier leur
bébés à des couples de personnes de même
sexe le projet familial des couples de
même sexe ne sera pas différent de celui
de toutes les personnes qui ont accès
aujourd'hui à
l'adoption le désir de fonder une
famille est
légitime le désir d'adopter un enfant
jeune et sans handicap important l' tout
autant dans les pays d'origine les
mesures de protection de l'enfance et
l'adoption nationale se
développe les enfants en basage et en
bonne santé trouvent une famille
adoptive dans leur pays de naissance
c'est le principe de
subsidiarité la probabilité est grande
voire très grande pour que les
propositions d'enfant portent sur des
frattereries de plus de tro
enfants des enfants grands 6 ans 8 ans
et même plus des enfants porteurs de
handicap autant d'adoption à risque tant
pour les enfants que pour les
couples dans les pays partis à la
convention de la haie au moment du
jugement l'enfant donne son accord à
l'adoption l'enfant donnera son accord
pour partir avec de papas ou avec de
mamans il donnera son accord pour avoir
une
famille famille qu'il n'a cependant pas
conceptualisé aucune mesure n'est prévue
pour préparer puis ensuite encadrer ces
adoptions à
risque l'adoption par les couples de
même sexe ne peut-être une adoption par
défaut adopter un enfant grand adopter
une frattererie de grands enfants parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre possibilité de
fonder une famille n'est pas
envisageable le projet d'adoption doit
être cerné et en adéquation avec les
capacités des
familles l'enfant doit pouvoir se
développer dans un milieu
harmonieux la responsabilité à l'égard
des pays d'origine les OAS sont en
relation permanente et pérenne avec les
pays d'origine l'expérience des OAS
permet de décrypter et connaître les
critères de sélection des candidats à
l'étranger les pays d'origine sont
souverains
quelques pays d'origine ont recensé
comme pouvant proposer des
apparentements au couple de personnes de
même sexe ces pays sont l'Afrique du Sud
certains états du Brésil les États-Unis
et le district fédéral de
Mexico en Afrique du Sud neu adoptions
été enregistré en 2012 le quotat de
dossier est atteint l'AT habilité ne
peut plus présenter de nouveaux dossiers
au Brésil 13 adoptions à préciser qu'il
s'agit de frattererie et d'enfants
grands et que les OAS présents au Brésil
pensent ne plus maintenir leur
habilitation les enfants sont grands les
enfants sont en fratterie nombreus et
ils n'ont pas les familles pouvant les
accueillir les États-Unis je crois qu'
les Américains ont déjà leur propres
candidats au Mexique zéro adoption
depuis 2 ans la ville de Mexico est
excessivement sélective pour
l'acceptation dans des
dossiers les enfants proposés par le
DIF national de Mexico souffrent de
pathologie excessivement
lourd ces enfants ne correspondent pas
au projet des familles voilà les pays
qui sont proposé comme étant possible à
l'adoption pour les couples de personnes
de même sexe il y en aura peut-être
d'autres la lecture des chiffres est
sans ambigué peu de familles de couples
de personnes de de même sexe verront ce
se concrétiser leur projet de famille
leur candidature n'étant pas recevable
ou peu recevable et dans des pays peu
ouvert à
l'adoption plusieurs opérateurs
partagent la crainte que certains pays
d'origine qui acceptent les candidatures
de célibataire ferme la porte aux
adoptions monoparentales par crainte
d'homosexualité non signifiée dans les
rapports d'enquête sociale et
psychologique bien que réfuté par
certains cet argument n'est pas un
néglige
les avancées en matière de modèle de
structure familial sont très différentes
d'un pays à l'autre un contreexemple
cependant peut-être donné avec l'Espagne
l'Espagne est le troisème pays d'accueil
des enfants et l'Espagne a légalisé le
mariage pour tous en
2005 là aussi en adoption internationale
on peut se demander quelle famille la
mère biologique qui a souhaité pour son
enfant quelle famille a-t-elle souhaité
cette mère biologique sans doute pas une
une famille qui n'entre dans son schéma
familial responsabilité à l'égard des
enfants les enfants sont les premiers
concernés ce sont eux qui doivent être
au cœur de notre mobilisation
indépendamment des évolutions sociales
c'est vers l'enfant et pour l'enfant que
doivent converger toutes nos
propositions les enfants ne peuvent être
au débat d'un au cœur d'un débat sur
l'égalité des couples
il est obligatoire que l'adoption fasse
l'objet d'une réflexion dissociée du
contexte passionnel actuel une réflexion
centrée sur l'enfant une réflexion où
l'enfant a sa place en tant que
personne dire que l'adoption n'est pas
un droit à l'enfant est une vérité qui
s'applique à tous les types de famille
homo ou
hétérosexuel il est aussi essentiel de
se souvenir que l'adoption est une
mesure de protection de l'
enfance la protection de l'enfance les
oa la revendiqueent sur le long terme
l'adoption ne s'arrête pas l'arrivée de
l'enfant les oa le savent les OAS savent
que les adoptés ont besoin de se situer
pour assumer la différence qu'il
porortte en eux pour assumer une
histoire faite de rupture de séparation
et parfois de violence pour assumer une
filiation biologique et une filiation
adoptive le désir de enfant adopté est
d'être un enfant comme les autres malgré
ces
différences la famille constituée par
deux personnes de même sexe sera une
différence supplémentaire à
assumer les enfants adoptés sont
régulièrement interpellés sur leurs
vrais parents et sur leurs faux parents
ils auront aussi à répondre de parents
identique la discrimination ethnique
existe dès la cours de récréation elle
risque d'être amplifiée par la
discrimination familiale
amplifié aussi lorsque l'enfant devenu
adolescent puis adulte fournira un acte
de naissance
spécifique tout enfant adopté a besoin
qu'un jour son histoire d'adoption
s'arrête son adoption ne regarde que lui
elle n'a pas à être rendue
publique l'enfant adopté fragilisé par
son histoire personnelle même s'il peut
donner ession de l'assumer sans
difficulté
apparente un accompagnement par des
mesures adéquates doit être facilité
pour les enfants et les familles qui le
nécessitent la construction identitaire
s'affaire souvent difficile pour les
adopter faire coexister une filiation
biologique et une filiation à l'égard de
deux parents de même sexe est un
obstacle supplémentaire à l'acquisition
des repères
stables des je je ayant des parents de
même sexe sont exprimés tépoignant d'un
parfait équilibre et d'un grand respect
pour le famille ces jeunes ont vécu
depuis leur tentre enfance dans un
univers aimant et sécure certains sont
en relation avec le parent de l'autre
sexe ces jeunes n'ont pas été fragilisés
par une enfiance violente par une
histoire douloureuse par des rejets
successifs l'enfant adopté grand ce qui
sera le
pour l'adoption des couples de même sexe
est un enfant blessé par son passé c'est
là une différence majeure qui doit être
prise en
considération la représentation
symbolique fait partie de la
construction de l'enfant
elle a souvent été mise à mal chez les
enfants adoptés grands l'identité
sexuelle des deux parents peut rendre
plus difficile la représentation du
référent de sexe
opposé pour se construire l'enfant doit
s'inscrire dans une lignée filiative
faite au départ de différen biologique
l'identité des sexes ne peut y trouver
de
sens il n'y aura pas de consensus sur la
structure familiale à retenir ou à ne
pas retenir les OAS tout comme les pays
d'origine divergent dans leur approche
de la famille idéale il y a par contre
un consensus sur le droit de l'enfant à
vivre dans une famille choisie pour lui
et adapté au parcours qui a été le
sien sur l'encadrement nécessaire à
donner à son
épanouissement la réflexion sur
l'ouverture de l'adoption au couple de
même sexe doit dépasser le cadre du
projet de
loi les consultations des acteurs de
l'adoption ont été trop
tardives parler de l'adoption c'est
connaître l'adoption à travers le vécu
des enfants et des familles pour pour
éviter tous les amalgames entre vérité
contre
vérité la réflexion doit être menée pour
l'enfant en tenant compte de l'évolution
du profil des enfants adoptables des
évolutions de la société elle ne
peut-être
parcellire toutes les formes de
l'adoption nationale internationale en
fond du conjoint sont à sécuriser tous
les acteurs de l'adoption sont concernés
chacun a ses références et ses
spécificités
le projet de loi aussi polémique qu'il
soit aura peut-être le mérite de
rappeler qu'une réforme de l'adoption
est nécessaire pour mieux garantir
l'intérêt des enfants et l'élaboration
de projets parentaux ouverts aux enfants
attendu merci merci à vous madame pour
cette contribution très intéressante
pour nous donc je donne la parole
successivement au trois autres
associations je vous demande pas de
diviser votre en 26 le temps de madame
Rio mais je vous demande de parler
chacun 5 6 minutes Maxim désolé non non
vous représentez 26 associations donc
si enfin c'est une pédanterie monsur je
suis plus grosse quand même bien et ben
nous allons essayer de faire plus court
eu le donc le le mouvement pour
l'adoption sans frontièr ne compte lui
que neuf associations de de parents
d'enfants de pays d'origine donc de
parents qui ont adopté dans un pays
donné mais représente néanmoins environ
plus de 3000 familles qui ont adopté
principalement à
l'international le la France va sans
doute autoriser le mariage pour tous
ainsi que l'adoption par les couples de
même sexe alors il existe au sein du
mmasf je dirais des et et des app au qui
en sont membres des divergences de vue
et je dirais que les divergences de vu
que l'on que l'on a vu dans la société
français au cours des dernières semaines
trouvent leur réplique au sein de nos
associations le masasf qui plusé
n'entend pas se positionner sur le
mariage pour tous puisqu'il s'agit de
d'un sujet qui ne concerne que des
adultes et qui est en dehors de notre
sphère d'intérêt même si nous avons tous
une opinion euh nous nous centrons avant
tout sur la partie du texte et notre
intérêt est avant tout sur la partie du
texte qui concerne l'adoption d'enfants
par les familles homoparentales la prier
le premier appel que nous souhaiterions
faire c'est que l'adoption est une
institution comme l'a rappelé
Marie-Christine Rio qui permet à un
enfant en privé de famille à la
naissance ou plus tardivement de trouver
une famille où il pourra s'épanouir et
grandir je mentionne à la naissance ou
euh plus tard car un des une des choses
erronées que l'on entend au sujet de
l'adoption c'est qu'on adopte des
orphelins c'était peut-être le cas en
1923 à la suite de la grande guerre mais
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui plus de
95 % des enfants adoptés ne sont pas
orphelins et je crois qu'il y a dans la
euh dans notre population des erreurs
sur ce sur ce point les familles donc
dans l'incapacité d'avoir un enfant
biologique n'ont pas droit à un enfant
qu'ell soit monoparental homoparental ou
hétéroparental elles ont la possibilité
en France de demander un agrément au fin
de s voir confier un enfant en
adoption le MASF souhaite surtout
attirer l'attention des sénateurs et de
la Commission sur la véritable portée
des mesures envisagées que je pourrais
résumer par euh par cette ce titre paru
récemment sur le site d'un hebdomadaire
de grande de grande d'bdomadaire
L'Express pour pour lui faire un peu de
publicité mariage pour tous et adoption
pour personne je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le projet arrive à un
moment où l'adoption à l'international
qui est le cœur de notre qui est le cœur
de notre intérêt notre principal intérêt
traverse une grave crise et aujourd'hui
rien ne permet de penser qu'un projet
construit existe pour mettre à à mal la
tendance que l'on constate depuis
plusieurs années
à savoir une baisse significative des
adoptions prononcées en faveur de
français à
l'étranger je vais donc essayer de de
structurer mon propos assez rapidement
le le premier sujet que je voudrais
aborder pardon c'est l'homoparentalité
et l'adoption nationale il y a eu en
2011 selon le rapport de l'ONED
761 561 enfants proposés à l'adoption
euh et je dirais cette propension et est
est à peu près stable voire en légère
diminution au cours des années la
question que pose le MASF est de savoir
comment seront appréciés demain les
qualités relatives des familles
monoparentales homoparentales ou
hétéroparentales et quels sont les
moyens qui seront alloués à la
préparation des enfants et des famill
ainsi qu'au suivi après l'adoption le
masasf entend de défendre les familles
adoptives dans leur pluralité et espère
que le projet de loi ne donnera pas lieu
dans sa mise en œuvre à une sorte de
classement euh public ou caché de ces
familles euh nous voulons également
signaler contrairement à certaines idées
reçues qu'il n'y aura sans doute pas
dans ce domaine de bouleversement comme
on entend parfois puisque dans des pays
qui ont autorisé l'adoption par les
couples gay et lesbiens comme la
Belgique depuis 2006 il n'y a eu que
neuf adoptions donc sur ce point je
crois que il faut
euh se poser la question de quelle sera
véritablement la portée du texte
s'agissant de l'adoption internationale
maintenant euh la réponse est à peu près
la même et dans le et dans la ligne de
ce que j'exposais préalablement je ne
reviendrai pas sur les chiffres de Marie
Christine Ryou et sur les pays qui
permettent l'adoption internationale je
ne ferai qu'une remarque mais qui me
paraît importante importante aussi parce
qu'elle va à l'encontre d'une idée reçue
on nous dit il n'y a plus d' il n'y a
plus d'enfants à adopter à
l'international ceci est une compte
vérité puisque les États-Unis ont publié
il n'y a pas plus de 1 mois il y a moins
d'un mois et c'est vous pourrez trouver
les références sur notre texte il y a un
communiqué de laassociété de Press qui
dit il y a 104000 enfants adoptables aux
États-Unis alors certes ils sont
généralement afro-américains ou
espagnols mais ils existent et ces
enfants ont également droit à des
familles s'agissant des pays dans
lesquels effectivement la France fait la
majorité de ses adoption il est clair là
qu'en revanche l'ouverture d'esprit
n'est pas équivalente à la France et le
premier pays dont sont originaires les
enfants adoptés en France à savoir la
Russie qui en 2012 a permis l'arrivée de
235 enfants a clairement indiqué à la
par le son représentant des droits de
l'homme mais aussi par le délégué du
président russe pour les droits de
l'enfant que la Russie souhaiterait
revoir le traité bilatéral signé en 2012
et doit trou et je dirais le a indiqué
également que s'agiss ag des
dispositions s'agissant des conventions
avec les Britanniques et les Français
les deux pays ont légalisé le mariage
homosexuel cela réduira les possibilités
en Russie donc il y a clairement chez
certains pays ne le cachons pas des euh
des des peurs vis-à-vis de l'adoption
par des couples homosexuels alors je
crois que là il ne s'agit pas de se
prononcer sur la vision des différents
pays l'important est de selon nous que
la France ne cache pas la réalité et
donc donc le masasf réitère le souhait
qu'il a déjà exprimé notamment au
Conseil supérieur de l'adoption que les
rapports sociaux établis en vue de
l'agrément décrivent de manière
transparente les familles qu'elles soi
homosexuelles ou hétérosexuell il nous
paraît particulièrement inapproprié
qu'un couple ne se déclare pas
explicitement dans sa réalité tant lors
de l'agrément que vis-à-vis des
autorités en charge de l'adoption dans
le pays d'origine des
enfants comme l'a rappelé un des plus
anciens membres du CSA l'adoption ne se
construit pas sur un mensonge
en le qui me paraît le plus important et
ce qui selon nous est le la porté majeur
du texte que nous av que que qui va être
discuté au Sénat euh c'est que
finalement la véritable portée de ce
texte en matière d'adoption c'est
l'adoption de l'enfant du
conjoint les estimations les plus
courantes font état d'au moins 50000
enfants présents aujourd'hui dans des
familles homoparentales françaises et
pour ces enfants le MASF considère que
le projet de loi constitue une réelle
avancée puisqu'il permettra de donner un
statut au second parents et donc une
sécurité dans le temps aux enfants du
couple comblant ainsi vide juridique
dans lequel se trouve encore de
nombreuses familles l'adoption de cet
enfant se fera soit de façon simple soit
de façon plainiare il semble que sur la
deuxième forme d'adoption qui est plus
sécurisante pour l'enfant il y a un
débat au sein des juristes qui a
commencé la semaine passée et donc qui
est un peu trop technique pour que nous
donnions notre opinion de façon plus
générale et comme je le disais
préalablement euh le souci pour nous
c'est l'adoption sa réalité et comme
nous l'avons déjà écrit est-ce que
demain l'adoption ne sera pas une
fiction nous souhaitons que le futur
projet de loi sur la famille puisqueà
priori le législateur a décidé de
scinder les choses en deux qui devait
originellement sortir au mois de mars
nous espérons que ce projet de loi
permettra de repenser en profondeur
notre modèle de l'adoption et notamment
nous insistons sur quatre priorités la
première réformer et professionnaliser
l'adoption international si l'on regarde
aujourd'hui nos organismes agréés par
l'adaption seul quatre d'entre eux font
plus de 50 adoptions par an il
fonctionne avec peu de moyens il n'est
pas il pas là ici je ne veux pas ici
leur porter de critique je dis
simplement que aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas des structures qui permettent un
maintien du N d'adoption internationale
et qui permettent le plus ce qui nous
paraît le plus important de pouvoir
trouver une famille pour des enfants
l'année 2011 selon l'ancien responsable
du service des adoptions internationales
devait être l'année des oa nous n'avons
rien vu nous voudrons également deuxième
priorité réaffirmer la prééminence de
l'adoption pliniiaire comme meilleure
protection des droits des enfants
celle-ci en effet permet l'égalité entre
les modes de
filiation même si souvent on considère
l'adoption comme une F de seconde zone
que ce soit dans les médias ou dans les
tribunaux et comme en témoigne notamment
le refus des conversions en plinière des
adoption des enfants venant d'Haïti et
nous voudrions également queon n'oublie
pas les axes de la proposition de loi
Tabarot notamment en matière d'enfance
délaissée qui avait pour effet de
permettre le de permettre aux enfants
d'accéder plus facilement au statut de
pupille de l'État euh et possiblement
ensuite d'être adopté
je ne m'étendrais pas eu égard aux
contraintes de temps sur la réforme et
la professionionalisation de l'adoption
internationale je dirais simplement que
contrairement à certains pays proches de
la France et notamment l'Italie la
France a vu au cours des tris dernières
années son nombre d'adoption
internationale passé de près de 4000 à
1569 en 2012 et il serait bon de
s'interroger sur les raisons de cette
décroissance quand l'ONC s'en parler
alors certes au niveau international on
note également une réduction des
adoptions internationales puisqu'elles
sont passées également globalement au
niveau mondial de 30000 à 22000 au cours
des dernières années simplement la
France va beaucoup plus vite dans cette
réduction et contrairement à des idées
reçues je ne pense pas même si la Russie
nous a indiqué qu'elle serait le
contraire que l'arrivée du de la loi
mariage pour tous va changer la donne
puisque nous sommes déjà en décroissance
plus forte que les autres la seule
remarque que l'on pourrait faire et qui
me paraî intér intessante à ce sujet
c'est justement lorsqu'on parle de cet
exemple russe il y avait en 2011 286
adoptions dont plus de Don près de 80 %
faites par la voie individuelle cette
année il y en a plus que 235 fait par
adoption individuelle dont 195 fait par
adoption individuelle donc à peu près 80
% et il n'y a eu que deux oa qui ont
fait des adoptions en Russie cette année
pour 35 de par la convention bilatérale
qui a été signée entre la France et la
Russie on peut donc prévoir que si la
France ratifie cette convention
prochainement et bien nous passerons
d'environ 235 à environ 50 car je ne
pense sans porter encore une fois
atteinte aux qualités des OAS que les
OAS ne pourront pas faire de 35 à 200
adoptions l'année prochaine je pense
qu'elles nont pas les moyens finalement
et pour conclure nous voudrions
réaffirmer la prééminence de l'adoption
internationale et nous pensons que
aujourd'hui face aux attaques qui sont
qui lui sont portées nous voudrions
rappeler cinq choses premièrement
la la l'adoption plainiare et l'adoption
qui est prévue dans la majorité des
États de l'Union européenne seuls les
Belges ont une adoption plinière et une
adoption simple et donc à la lecture de
cette loi ou de la loi sur la famille
nous demandons pourquoi ce qui marche
très bien dans les autres pays européens
ne marcherait pas en France deuxièmement
la convention de la par laquelle à
laquelle la France est partie prévoit
que les les états d'accueil des enfants
adoptés doivent prononcer une adoption
les liens avec la famille d'origine si
l'état de l'origine de l'enfant a
prononcé une adoption enortant une telle
rupture si demain il y avait devait y
avoir une nouvelle forme d'adoption on
entend ceci la question que nous nous
posons c'est est-ce que cette nouvelle
adoption sera conforme à la Convention
de lae 3è point il nous paraît important
de rappeler que dans l'adoption
pliniiaire aucun secret n'est maintenu
vis-à-vis de l'adopté s'agissant de
l'adoption internationale l'acte
intégral de naissance mentionne adoption
et le lieu de naissance réelle de
l'enfant ce sont les extraits de
naissance qui thèsent à juste titre
selon nous l'adoption qui n'a pas être
affiché sur un texte public puisqu'elle
appartient à l'histoire intime de
l'adopté et pour finir nous avons
indiqué et si vous avez nous avons signé
avec efa qui se trouve à notre droite et
la voix des adoptés ainsi que Racine
cohérenne une 2è association d'adopté
une tribune le 24 janvier dernier dans
laquelle nous mentionnons euh notre
attachement à la plinière dans l'intérêt
pr prioritairement des enfants et nous
rappelons que si la France veut se
donner les moyens elle a un outil qui
s'appelle le knaop qui aujourd'hui ne
s'intéresse qu'aux adoptions national
mais qui pourrait valablement euh
étendre son champ d'action avec
néanmoins certaines limites lorsque au
Kazakhstan on dépose un enfant on est
susceptible de la peine de mort il sera
donc difficile pour nos enfants venant
du Kazakhstan de remonter les origines
de l'enfant puisque et majoritaire
majoritairement dans les cas le père est
absent et c'est la femme qui abandonne
l'enfant il est fort à croire que les
femmes auront du mal à donner leur
identité puisqu'elles sont susceptibles
de la peine de mort dans ce pays je vous
remercie merci pour ces éléments
complémentaire on peut dire hein donc
Madame parent vous avez la parole merci
monsieur je vous remercie de me recevoir
au nom des 9000 familles actuellement
adhérentes à efa et des 200000 enfants à
adopté dont les parents ont rejoint efa
depuis sa création il y a 60 ans ces
9000 familles sont constituées de
familles adoptives de candidats à
l'adoption et d'adopter majeur en
quelques mots efa est un mouvement
apolitique laïque est indépendant qui
regroupe 93 associations départementales
nous siégeons dans les conseils de
famille des pupilles de l'État et dans
une majorité de commission d'agrément
des conseils généraux au niveau national
nous sommes membres du Conseil supérieur
de l'adoption du Conseil national pour
l'accès aux origines personnel et du
comité de suivi de l'Agence Française de
l'Adoption photographie de la société
d'aujourd'hui les familles adérant à efa
sont des familles monoparentales marié
divorcé recomposé multirecomposé
hétérosexuel ou homosexuel en
concubinage ou paxé até de religion
catholique protestante musulmane juif et
cetera parmi celles-ci certaines
s'inquiètent d'une évolution des schémas
familiaux qui bousculent leur
représentation d'autres y voient la
possibilité de proposer une palette
élargie de famille à des enfants qui
attendent d'autres encore hésitent aussi
s'interrogent ou n'ont pas d'opinion
néanmoins une conviction fait consensus
nul n'a le droit d'instrumentaliser les
enfants de les brandir comme des
étandards que ce soit ceux qui
s'opposent à l'évolution législative ou
ceux qui la soutiennent or ce sont
aujourd'hui les enfants qui sont les
premières victimes de ce débat que ce
soit ceux qui vivent dans des familles
homoparentales et ou ceux qui sont
adoptés il semble indispensable de
revenir dans ce débat à la protection de
l'intérêt de l'enfant privé de famille
et non d'exacerber la revendication d'un
droit à l'enfant des adultes il s'agit
bien ici du droit de l'enfant à avoir
une famille mesure de protection de
l'enfance pour un enfant qui en est
dépourvu telle que prévue dans la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant de
plus qu'une égalité de droit entre les
adultes nous devons garantir les droits
de l'enfant privé de famille les débats
autour de ce projet de loi ont fait
émerger des croyances indignes
diabolisant toutes les formes de
familles non biologiques et ont fait
apparaître les familles adoptives comme
des familles fictives de fausses
familles laaffiliation adoptive comme
une filiation à risque et les adopter
comme des citoyens de seconde catégorie
les enfants adopt leur famille mérit
mieux que d'être vu à travers le prisme
des préjugés et des
amalgames certains débutés ont préconisé
l'adoption simple lors des débats à
l'Assemblée nationale au motif qu'elle
serait plus respectueuse de l'histoire
des enfants et de leur éventuell
recherche d'origine quelques-uns allant
jusqu'à proposer la suppression de
l'adoption
plinièire l'adoption simple serait à
leurs yeux plus accepable parce qu'elle
garde la trace des liens du sang et
qu'elle épouse ainsi la vraieemblance de
la conception tout en créant une vraie
filiation qui s'ajoute à la première
lorsque la première a été établie en ne
l'effaçant pas de ce fait l'adoption
simple uniquement par des couples de
même sexe apparaîtrait comme moins
inacceptable un moindre m c'est oublié
tout d'abord que les enfants délaissés
séparés ou retirés à leurs parents
n'attendent pas de la société une
solution qui lui serait idéologiquement
acceptable mais mais une filiation
sécurisée à part entière c'est oublié
aussi que l'adoption dans sa forme
pliniiare n'a jamais été en soi un
obstacle pour la recherche des origines
ce n'est pas l'adoption pliniiaère qui
rend leur recherche cruelle et aléatoire
c'est niquement le fait que les parents
de naissance n'ont pas laissé de trace
pour l'enfant qu'ils ont mis au monde
que ce soit volontairement comme ou
comme l'a dit Marc lasser parce que
l'abandon estible de peine de mort dans
le pays d'origine
l'adoption pliniiare majoritaire à
travers le monde romp les liens
juridiques elle ne crée ni l'effacement
de ce qui a été dit et acté ni l'oubli
de ce qui a été vécu tous les éléments
de l'histoire antérieure quand ils
existent parce que les parents les
services ou les États les ont
communiqués sont conservés dans les
dossiers dans le jugement c'est oubliez
enfin que si les conditions juridiques
de l'adoptabilité Horm l'âge sont les
mêmes pour la l'adoption simple et
l'adoption pliniiare l'un et l'autre ne
répondent pas au mêmes vides aux mêmes
besoins aux mêmes attentes et que l'on
ne saurait à priori considérer que
l'adoption simple est une solution
acceptable uniquement parce qu'elle
maintient l'enfant dans les liens
juridiques qu'il est parfois souhaitable
de trancher pour que l'enfant ait une
chance de
s'épanouir aujourd'hui certains souhait
aménager le droit de l'adoption à l'ône
de la vraissemblance biologique voir
différemment selon les adultes qui la
demandent l'adoption n'est pas une
filiation à géométrie variable inventée
pour répondre au manqu ou au désirs des
adultes elle est chaque fois dans l'une
ou dans l'autre de ces formes la réponse
unique pour chacun des enfants au
bénéfice duquel elle est prononcée si
elle doit être plainère ou simple ce
n'est donc que pour lui que la loi doit
en tracer les contours et non en
fonction de l'orientation sexuel ou du
statut des adoptants si l'on peut se
réjouir que contrairement au projet de
loi les règles d'attribution du nom de
famille soit identique pour tous les
enfants quel que soit leur mode de
filiation des questions se posent
concernant les actes d'état civil et
plus particulièrement les extraits
d'actes portant mention de la filiation
parce que toutes les filiations sont
égales et qu'il n'est pas possible de
faire apparaître sur des documents
destinés à tout public le mode
d'établissement de la filiation les
extraits d'actes tels qu'ils existent
font tous les enfants adopté ou non
symboliquement nés de leurs parents il
vaudrait mieux donc puisque ce sont des
extraits faant mention de l'affiliation
qu'ils énoncent tous fils d'eux ou fille
d'eux une demande qu'enfants et familles
d'adoption formulé déjà devant votre
commission et devant la commission mixte
de l'Assemblée nationale durant les
débats de la loi de 1980
portant réforme de l'adoption si comme
l'ont laissait entendre le Conseil
d'État et certains magistrats
l'établissement des actes d'état civil
pour les enfants adoptés pliniiairement
par des couples de même sexe devaent
être déclaré anticonstitutionnel il ne
pourrait avoir pour conséquence la
suppression ou l'amenuisement des droits
des enfants adoptés sous la forme
plinière une discrimination qui serait
tout encore plus
anticonstitutionnelle un acte d'état
civil relève de intime quel que soit le
mode d'établissement de
l'affiliation si le Sénat devait voter
ce projet de loi dans les mêmes termes
que la fait l'Assemblée nationale le 12
février dernier les couples de même sexe
pourront tout comme les couples de sexes
différents solliciter un agrément dans
les mêmes conditions d'âge et d'années
de mariage aujourd'hui on ne peut que
constater et regretter que les couples
non mariés quels qu'ils soi sollicitent
un agrément en taisant le plus souvent
une partie de leur vie
si l'on souhaite que l'adoption soit
réellement prononcée au bénéfice de
l'enfant on ne peut accepter l'idée
qu'il vive avec le partenaire de son
parent sans que celui-ci ne soit
entièrement partie prenante dès le
départ ne s'y soit préparé lui aussi et
que ses capacités parentales n'ai pas
été vérifié la transparence du projet
parental est une condition indispensable
et nécessaire pour garantir
l'inscription de l'enfant dans sa
nouvelle famille même si aujourd'hui
l'adoption par les couples de même sexe
concerne principalement l'adoption de
l'enfant du conjoint et non l'adoption
nationale et encore moins international
il est nécessaire que les pouvoirs
publics si le projet de loi est voté
s'assur que les candidatures des couple
de même sexe soi traité sans
discrimination tant au niveau de la
procédure d'agrément que dans les
démarches d'adoption en France et à
l'étranger dans le respect des
législations ce risque de discrimination
ne peut être or au-delà de sa famille
l'enfant adopté a besoin de s'inscrire
dans la société qui l'entoure or le
débat actuel accentue les
discriminations les propos entendus ces
derniers temps sont déjà profondément
choquants pour tous les enfants adoptés
et encore plus pour les enfants
actuellement élevés par des parents de
même sexe l'absence de connaissance de
son patrimoine génétique n'est pas une
tard
irréparable la famille biologique n'est
pas vérité et la famille adoptive
fiction
les enfants adoptés peuvent se
construire dans leur famille adoptive
même si parfois cela peut être difficile
comme il peut être impossible de grandir
dans une famille biologique comme en
témoigne le nombre important d'enfants
placés c'est aux élus de la République
et à travers eux à la société dans son
ensemble de rendre aux enfants les
droits qui leur reviennent l'adoption
est avant tout une mesure de protection
de l'enfance une réponse aux besoins de
l'enfant elle ne peut être regardée
comme la réponse ni à la générosité ni à
la stérilité médicale ou sociale les
familles du 21e siècle sont multiplles
et les enfants qui vivent en leur sein
sont tous légitimes et ne doivent pas
faire l'objet d'une quelconque
discrimination de par leur mode de
filiation comme les autres familles la
famille adoptive
hétéroparentale monoparental et
peut-être demain
homoarental n'est pas un artefact
c'est une filiation sociale tout comme
les filiations fondées sur la biologie
qui n'ont socialement d'existence que
lorsqu'un acte juridique les constate je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame par mais
nous donc je la parole à Madame février
et donc nous aurons largement une
demi-heure pour poser des
questions monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier au
nom de la voix des adoptés de l'avoir
invité à s'exprimer dans le cadre des
auditions consacré au projet de loi
ouvrant le mariage au couplle de même
sexe l'association la voie des adoptés
créée en 2005 à politique et laïque agit
maintenant via qure antaines depuis 8
ans Paris Lyon rouan et Toulouse et des
permanences à la maison de l'adoption de
lîle et de Lyon la voix des adoptés
compte à ce jour 215 adhérents de toute
orig y compris de France correspondant à
de nombreux profils d'adopté appartenant
à des familles adoptives très varié
adoption nationale pupille de l'État né
sous X adoption internationale quel que
soit le continent d'origine quel que
soit le type d'adoption simple ou plère
en famille monoparentale divorcé
recomposé adoption en fraterie adopté
grand et
cetera actuellement toutefois aucun
membre de la voix des adoptés n'est un
adopté de famille homoparentale cet état
de faête ne vient pas d'une volonté de
notre association il est possible que
notre association ne les intéresse pas
ou qu'il n'ose pas nous rejoindre car
pour certains adoptés sachez mesdames et
Messieurs les sédateurs qu'adhérer ou
participer à une association d'adoptés
peut être déjà représenté un engagement
personnel parfois difficile à à
franchir forte de notre expérience vécu
et partagé la voix des adopté reste
nuancé à propos du projet de loi et
souhaite faire part aujourd'hui de
quelques pistes de réflexion
concernant le mariage entre deux
personnes de même sexe la notion de
mariage n'impliquant pas forcément celle
de l'adoption j'entends qu'on peut se
marier et pas forcément adopter la voix
des adoptés ne se prononcera pas sur le
mariage entre deux personnes de même
sexe dans l'adoption il se joue une mise
en relation d'enfants mineurs avec des
adultes ce qui est différent du contexte
du mariage qui implique deux personnes
majeures indépendante et en pleine
possession de leur capacité mentale dans
l'adoption les droits de l'adulte ne
doivent pas se substituer à ceux de
l'enfant c'est le droit de l'enfant qui
prime et le droit à l'enfant n'existe
pas concernant les modifications prévues
sur le Code civil dans le cadre de
l'adoption par les couples de même sexe
je souhaiterais juste rapidement revenir
sur l'état civil de l'adopté qui a été
évoqué par Madame parent
précédemment et rappeler effectivement
que dans le cadre de l'adoption pléiare
la transcription du jugement d'adoption
ou dans le livret de famille les termes
nés de
apparaissent
né de du parent adoptif dans le cadre de
l'application de cette loi les termes
pourraient être remplacés par fils de ou
fille de puisque être né de Monsieur Y
ou de Monsieur Z correspondrait à un non
sens physiologique de
fait je tiens à rappeler que nous nous
situons dans le débat la réflexion et la
discussion nous pensons que réduire un
tel débat sur l'ouverture du mariage et
de l'adoption couple de même sexe ne
peut répondre à une réponse tranchée
pour ou contre notre association je le
rappelle se situe dans
une de façon apolitique et
laïque concernant ce projet de loi et
l'adoption la voie des adoptés ne peut
s'opposer totalement au projet de loi si
nous étudion uniquement la variable sexe
l'expérience a montré que certains
adoptés ont grandi dans des familles
dont les parents étaient de sexe
différents et dans un environnement
social professionnel élevé et malgré
cela l'adoption s'est avéré difficile
les adoptés sont bien placés pour parler
de leurs évolutions et de ce qui les
rend heureux ou pas or certains adoptés
par un couple de parents de sexe
différents n'en sont pas toujours sortis
indemn la réussite entre guillemets tout
comme l'échec entre guillemets d'une
adoption ne dépend pas uniquement de la
variable sexe des parents c'est à
l'évidence la même observation peut être
faite pour les adoptions réalisées par
des célibataires certains adoptés ont eu
un bon développement postadoption tandis
que d'autres ont eu plus de difficultés
nous avons actu ement le recul et
expérience de terrain pour pouvoir
affirmer qu'adopter un enfant en couple
hétérosexuel ne signifie pas
systématiquement une stabilité de
l'enfant et de sa famille les familles
adoptantes sont également
représentatives de l'ensemble des
situations familiales existantes dans la
population générale c'est-à-dire des
parents adoptants qui se séparent
divorcent se remarient se recomposent et
on peut penser à la problématique de
l'arrivée d'enfant des enfants du
nouveau conjoint et cetera il existe
aussi des situations de décès de l'un
des parents
adoptifs
enfin l'adoption par des personnes de
même sexe vivant en couple existe déjà
mais de façon cachée àou via des
adoptions en tant que célibataire cette
situation actuellement favorise
l'absence de préparation et
d'accompagnement de l'enfant et du
postulant il serait important que cette
loi permette aujourd'hui de rendre
officielle une situation officieuse et
permett de mieux accompagner l'enfant et
ses parents dans ce type
d'adoption la voix des adoptés ne peut
approuver totalement le projet de loi
dans le sens où il nous semble essentiel
de prendre en compte le de prendre en
compte le passé de l'enfant et son
profil notamment le type de cellule
familiale dans laquelle il a vécu avant
son adoption a-t-il été adopté grand
dans quelle culture a-t-il vécu un
certain temps en famille d'accueil
famille au pluriel avec ses parents de
naissance ou dans une autre cellule
familiale avec un référent paternel ou
maternel l'adopté n'arrive pas vierge de
tout vécu ce n'est pas une page blanche
selon le la culture du pays d'origine et
l'environnement familial et social dans
lequel il aura grandi il aura certaines
attentes et besoins spécifiques envers
ses parents
adoptifs dans certains cas il aura
peut-être déjà appris à dire maman et à
distinguer les rôles de père et de mère
dans toutes les formations et
préparation aux postulants que nous
effections nous nous insistons sur
l'importance de penser et connaître le
vécu préadoptif de l'enfant par rapport
à l'influence éventuelle que cela
pourrait avoir dans son développement
durant la
postadoption l'autre facteur essentiel à
prendre en compte est l'importance de la
figure maternelle chez Les Adoptés je
pense notamment à la question de la
recherche des parents biologiques
puisque la demande première dans les
recherches est exprimée ainsi je
souhaite retrouver ma mère biologique le
terme de mère un sens particulier pour
les adoptés en effet ils en ont
forcément deux l'une biologique l'autre
adoptive ils définissent leur m
biologique selon leurs propres terme
cela leur appartient mère biologique
mère de naissance ou encore la femme qui
m'a mise au monde dans tous les cas
cette n'est que très rarement définie
par le thème de génitrice terme jugé
réducteur et ne représentant pas la
femme qui les a porté et mise au monde
la mère biologique existe bien au-delà
du simple sens ou acte de conception par
la suite la mère adoptive sera souvent
l'objet d'un amour infini ou à l'inverse
de haine cette ambivalence se traduisant
par des comportements parfois extrêmes
ce trop plein d'émotion peut permettre à
l'adopter d'exprimer sa blessure
primitive de l'abandon qu'il a subi
auparavant dans un tel contexte nous
nous interrogeons sur la manière dont
l'enfant adopté pourra se représenter sa
mère biologique notamment dans le cas
d'une adoption par des couples de même
sexe masculin il serait important de
penser à la présence d'une figure
maternelle àulle de référence ce que
certains pourraent appeler tuteur de
résilience au final notre questionnement
concerne particulièrement la prise en
charge des enfants et parents adoptifs
dans la post-adoption quel suivi et
quels accompagnement ces enfants et
leurs parents adoptifs auront-ils par
qui l'état a-t-il les moyens financiers
et humains de mettre en place une réelle
politique d'accompagnement de la
post-adoption les associations du monde
de l'adoption sont déjà de plus en plus
sollicitées parfois démunies il doiv
faire face à des demandes de plus en
plus lourdes et difficiles tout en
restant bénévoles et sans aucun soutien
financier force de constater que les
parents adoptifs et les Adoptés se sont
déjà parfois isolés et en totale absence
de soutien et
d'écoute concernant la réalité de
l'adoption en France nationale et
internationale cette question a été
abandée par les associations de parents
et les OA nous faisons partie de ce
constat là également quel sera le
contexte de l'adoption pour les couples
de même sexe étant donné le faible
niveau d'adoption internationale en
France concernant l'adoption nationale
la France est acteur de l'adoption tel
que l'AZ la DGCS les oa et cetera
sont-ils prêts à accorder des adoptions
par des couples de même sexe à accepter
en toute impartialité et à traiter les
dossiers à égalité avec les autres
postulants nous nous interrogeons par
exemple sur l'éventuelle formation des
professionnels de la protection de
l'enfance à à l'adoption par des couples
de même
sexe concernant les modes et les types
d'adoption quelle adoption sera réservée
à ces couples de même sexe simple ou
plinière nous sommes ici pour rappeler
que l'adoption simple est source
d'insécurité et qu'elle remet en cause
la filiation de l'adopté voir sa
nationalité notamment dans l'adoption
internationale il nous semble important
aujourd'hui de défendre plus que jamais
l'adoption pliniiaire dans le cadre
notamment de l'adoption internationale
en effet il faut appeler le caractère
révocable de l'adoption simple qui peut
placer l'adopté àinnational dans une
situation de doute et d'instabilité
quant à sa fination or les adoptés ont à
forcerie besoin de sécurité celle-ci
peut passer d'abord et avant tout par la
mise en place d'une sécurité juridique
via une adoption pleine entière et
irrévocable les adoptions simples
peuvent être en revanche pertinentes
dans les cas d'adoption de l'enfant du
conjoint ici d'un homoparent ayant
adopté en célibataire C ces adoptions
méritent d'être considéré et étudier au
cas par cas dans l'adoption dans
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant je
rappelle enfin que l'adoption plinière
n'est pas un empêchement à la recherche
des origines je rappelle également que
la recherche des origines n'est pas une
remise en cause de l'adoption pligniare
la recherche des origines n'est pas un
échec de l'adoption comm comme on a
voulu le faire entendre et comme on l'a
entendu dernièrement je rappelle
également des situations concrètes que
certains adoptés font effectuer leur
recherche avec leurs parents ils vont
même jusqu'au bout certains font la
démarche de rencontre de leur famille
biologique avec leurs parents
adoptifs l'adoption simple ne l'adoption
pliniiare ne change pas la question des
données écrites et déposées dans le
dossier cela a été rappelé effectivement
par les associations de parents en
France il y a l'accouchement sousiste à
l'international il y a des enfants
trouvés il y a des interdictions à
l'abandon punis et légiféré dans tous
les cas la démarche de déposer ou non
une identité et un nom et une identité
voir une histoire n'appartient qu'aux
personnes qui mettent l'enfant à
l'adoption il serait beaucoup plus
pertinent de se poser la question de
l'accès j'insiste bien à l'accès aux
origines tel qu'il a été évoqué par
parent notamment via le knaop et
notamment de recueillir au maximum à
définir selon les textes de loi une
histoire de l'enfant j'insiste bien sur
le terme histoire et ne pas forcer au
nom et à
l'identité concernant la préparation et
la accagnement des adoptés une nouvelle
fois nous nous questionnons sur la
préparation des enfants à l'adoption par
un couple de même sexe comment être en
accord avec les pays source ou avec la
sur l'importance d'une préparation à
l'adoption pour ses enfants une
formation des professionnels de
l'enfance intervenant durant la
procédure d'adoption à l'adoption par
des couples de même sexe doit être
envisagé vient un guide une formation
spécifique des supports médias une
communication de ce sens sera-t-elle
mise en place il nous semble fondamental
de préparer l'enfant au mieux avant son
adoption quel qu'il soit quels
accompagnements durant la post-adoption
l'adoption n'est pas un instant T
éphémère ou en rupture avec un avant et
un après l'adoption est une transition
entre deux histoires celle de l'enfant
et de ses nouveaux parents quel qu'ils
soi ensemble ils vont construire une
famille à cours moyen et surtout à long
terme adopter c'est pour la vie en
prenant conscience de l'adoption comme
une situation permanente nous nous
questionnons sur la mise en place d'un
accompagnement durant la post-adoption
des adoptés et de leur famillees il nous
semble nire nécessaire d'accompagner ces
familles dans leur évolution tenant
compte par exemple de leur construction
leur considération et répartition des
rôles masculins féminins le
développement des caractères sexuels et
de la différence des genres qui ne
présagent pas de leur propre orientation
sexuelle future propre à chacun et non
pathologique si des mesures préventives
et des des accompagnements existeront un
certain nombre de questions se posent
quant à leur mise en place effective
dans quelle structure par quel
service les adoptés ont plus que jamais
besoin d'un espace à eux nous proposons
dans ce cadre l'idée de la création d'un
service postadoption réservé aux
adoptés merci beaucoup mesdames
monsieurie donc je vais donner la parole
moi je ne poserai pas de question pour
laisser le temps simplement pour pour
pour vous dire que nous sommes tous très
conscients et notamment mes mes
collègues madame Meier qui est
rapporteur pour avis pour la commission
des affaires sociales et les membres de
la Commissar sociale qui sont là madame
Génisson et cetera que une réforme de
l'adoption est absolument nécessaire ça
ça me paraît évident et que donc nous
serons très attentifs à ce que sera la
loi famille ou la loi bioéthique enfin
je ne sais pas trop ce que ce sera
encore euh ça nous sommes tous très très
conscients de de ça simplement
volontairement euh dans le texte actuel
je ne pense pas que le Sénat ajoutera
des choses supplémentaires nous aurions
été tentés moi j'aurait été tenté par
exemple de prévoir l'adoption pour les
couples paxés par exemple parce qu'on
voit pas pourquoi les couples paxés
aujourd'hui en majorité hétérosexuel
n'ont pas le droit d'adopter alors que
les célibataires onont le droit en
cachant leur fait qu'ils sont
célibataires dans la plupart des cas
mais bon voilà donc nous voulons pas
surcharger le texteel qu'il est c'est
déjà assez lourd comme ça paraît-il
enfin pour certains mais nous serons
très attentifs à la suite des opérations
donc je donne tout de suite la parole à
Michel Menier ensuite aux sénatrices on
fera un global des questions comme ça
vous aurez encore jusqu'à 10h30 pour
répondre merci monsieur le Président
merci à chacune et à à chacun d'avoir
parlé de l'adoption dans ces termes
parce que jusqu'à présent j'avoue qu'on
a entendu ici mais surtout aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale pas mal de
contrevérités vous l'avez dit et d'idées
reçues et on a surtout aborder les
filiations sur leur angle biologique
hein pas seulement que les
psychanalystes mais aussi certaines
personnes des ordres religieux qu'on a
entendu euh et voilà et c'est pas
terminé donc merci pour à à vous de nous
de nous redire que l'adoption c'est une
mesure de protection de l'enfance et que
lorsqu'on parle d'adoption euh on donne
à l'enfant le droit d'avoir une famille
euh donc moi j'imagine euh que tous ces
ces contevérités ces idées reçues ces
dénigrement de l'adoption a dû traverser
vos vos associations de différentes
manières et que ça a dû euh aussi vous
faire réagir euh sur image des de de vos
familles puisque l'adoption existe vous
l'avez dit de différentes manières en
France moi je voulais revenir sur
peut-être le point d'accès aux origines
vous l'avez abordé monsieur lasser ou
madame parent je sais plus mais on a
entendu le fait que l'adoption
pliniiaire
couperait l'accès aux origines vous avez
dit que c'est c'était faux donc
peut-être que vous pourriez revenir
là-dessus et puis euh est-ce que une
question je me pose est-ce que c'est euh
nécessaire dans la construction d'un
enfant d'un adulte d'avoir accès à ses
origines quand on sait qu'elles peuvent
être
parfois douloureuses ou ou dramatiqu
parfois impossible hein euh voilà donc
je voulais peut-être avec le vécu et et
l'expérience que vous avez au travers de
des parents qui composent vosos
associations peut-être que vous n disiez
deux mots là-dessus et puis euh on a
bien entendu le besoin de la réforme de
la adoption avec la sécurité nécessaire
aussi bien dans le cadre juridique et
caractère définitif de l'adoption
plinièire par rapport à l'adoption
simple ou d'une troisième voix qu'on
pourrait imaginer mais que je ne
souhaite
pas merci merci Michel donc je j'ai cru
comprendre quand même que on a beaucoup
parlé ici de l'accès aux origines moi
j'ai toujours été très favorable mais je
crois comprendre parce que de toute
façon on apprend tous les jours que
plutôt de que de dire ça c'est m de dire
que l'enfant adopté doit connaître son
histoire antérieure voilà et ça me paraî
j'ai appris ça ce matin un peu ça me
paraît être plus plus plus vrai voilà
parce que dans certains cas pour pas
qu'on donc je vous don la parole après
alors
mesdames madame
prince
Catherine Catherine
génon
sur le truc rouge
voilà non monsieur d'abord vous
remercier monsieurs mesdames de de vos
témoignages qui sont très instructifs et
qui je pense comme comme vous monsieur
le rapporteur nous pose la obligation de
revoir globalement je pense le les
conditions de l'adoption euh globalement
peut-être plus que par rapport au sujet
de la nature du couple qui
va qui va qui qui qui est comment dire
candidat candidat à l'adoption moi c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai retenu de de vos
propos avec quand même pour tous les
couples j'ai envie de dire des
difficultés de plus en plus grandes pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir adopter et
apparemment ce sont des sujets qui ne
pourront pas s'améliorer sur le plan
international mais sur le plan national
et je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
que vraiment sur le plan national nous
avons urgence à revoir la les conditions
d'enfant délaissés abandonnés et qui
pour autant ne ne sont pas adoptables
donc je c'est plutôt de de de façon
globale que je vous ai écouté entendu à
juste titre les uns et les autres vous
n'avez porté aucun jugement et c'est
légitime sur ce qu'est le mariage de
couple homosexuel que ce soit des
couples femmes ou hommes et vous ne
semblez pas au-delà du fait que vous
avez mis euh les difficultés que
pouvaient représenter pour euh les pays
proposés proposant l'adoption ou aussi
euh l'enfant euh pouvant être adopté de
votre part le fait que ça pouvait
entraîner des difficultés particulières
parce que les uns et les autres vous
avez beaucoup insisté sur l'importance
de comment dire de l'environnement
affectif dont va pouvoir bénéficier la
la personne adoptée et que c'est ça qui
est fondamental et que enfin je pense
que c'est une enfin une comment dire un
constat qui commence à être approprié
par de plus en plus de personnes enfin
celles et ceux qui veulent écouter et en
tout cas merci beaucoup de votre de vos
témoignages qui sont très très
instructifs oui un petit mot moi aussi à
mon tour pour vous remercier pour vos
interventions particulièrement riches je
rejoindrai ce que vient de dire
Catherine Génisson ce qui a dit
auparavant Jean-Pierre Michel nous
sommes parfaitement consci ont des
difficultés liées à l'adoption vous les
avez ce matin détaillé enrichis
également mais comme l'a dit Jean-Pierre
Michel il s'agit pas d'alourdir le texte
tel que le le gouvernement nous le nous
le
présente ceci dit cela ne nous empêchera
pas bien évidemment d'insister de façon
assez forte sur la nécessité de
travailler beaucoup plus en profondeur
sur l'adoption donc je pense que nous
prendrons tout notre part avec force
dans le débat parlementaire pour pour
insister sur ce point qui est
extrêmement
important
euhon monsieur del notre collègue qui a
assisté à beaucoup
d'auditions je pense que vous lirez avec
profit et intérêt dans le compte-rendu
qui paraîtra dans le ou sur internet ce
qui vient d'être dit mais qu'on peut pas
redire malheureusement et qui est très
intéressant notamment non je pense au
questiono non mais non mais je non mais
si mais vous auriez pu la demander si
vous aviez parce que je pense notamment
aux questions que vous avez posé chaque
fois que vous étiez là d'ailleurs hier
et cetera sur les origines de l'enfant
la place de l'enfant dans le couple et
cetera et cetera et je crois que
là-dessus nous avons eu des plutôt des
témoignages que des prises de position
qui me paraissent très intéressants mais
on les reverra donc je donne la parole à
nos invités qui peuvent répondre chacun
à la suite et en même temps faire un un
genre de conclusion on
peut voilà alors prenez pas trop de
temps parce qu'à 10h30 j'arrête ça que
vous ayez parlé ou pas d'accord euh
rapidement donc sur la question de
l'accès aux origines euh je suis d'abord
honnêtement au nom de la voix des
adoptés déjà premièrement surprise que
l'on en parle autant dans le cadre de ce
projet de loi puisqueà priori je pensais
pas qu'on se pose autant la question de
des origines puisqu'on parle d'adoption
par des couples de même sexe euh ça met
en exerg apparemment cette fameuse
question qui n'est pas nouvelle du point
de vue des
adoptés par contre ce qui me dérange
c'est que on puisse s'en servir pour
s'opposer par exemple à ce projet de
loi pour répondre à votre question
madame est-ce nécessaire la construction
d'un
adulte oui et non voilà il est important
effectivement pour les Adoptés d'avoir
un minimum de connaissance de leur
histoire avoir des données euh je pense
que les personnes nées sous X ou euh
trouvé hein quand dans c'est le cas
notamment de l'adoption internationale
c'est enfants trouvé ou qu'on a
falsifier les documents parce que ça
existe hein je parle aussi notamment des
trafics d'enfants des événements récents
sont là pour nous le rappeler euh forme
un trouble effectivement assez important
dans le sens où euh de qui suis-je né
euh voilà c'est enfin ça c'est difficile
de se construire sur rien ils le disent
parfois j'ai l'impression de nêtre
d'être né de rien ni de personne voilà
donc effectivement je pense qu'un
minimum de connaissance sur ces origines
est important après c'est à l'adopter et
à personne d'autre de choisir le moment
de sa démarche de recherche voilà nous
par exemple on ne fait pas de démarche
de recherche pour des mineurs parce
qu'on estime qu'ils ne sont pas encore
prêt donc dans le casadre par exemple
d'une adoption simple ce serait lui
imposer un lien et une filiation d'emblé
via la voie des adopté nous avons des
exemples de personnes en adoption simple
ou dans des situations proches telles
que la Polynésie qui qui a ce typ de
structure honnêtement ça n'a rien
favorisé du tout voire même il y a eu
des moments de rupture de lien avec la
famille biologique tellement il y avait
une emprise sans parler je parle
notamment de l'adoption internationale
je rappelle des conditions financières
c'estàd qu'il y a des liens financiers
qui se jouent et l'adopté se retrouve en
dette
parfois enfance c'est famille
d'adoption je voudrais juste répondre à
Madame sur tout ce qui est
accompagnement Cécile février l'a dit
sur la accagnement des adoptés je crois
qu'aujourd'hui dans une réforme globale
de l'adoption c'est un accompagnement et
une préparation aussi bien des
postulants mais également des parents et
des enfants qui arrivent je voudrais
quand même rappeler que Madame Rio l'a
dit le profil des enfants se modifie en
arrive en international on voit que les
enfants sont plus grands qu'on a de plus
en plus d'enfants à besoins spécifiques
que nos enfants n'arrivent pas vierg
c'est pas une page blanche chez des
enfants qui ont qui ont des histoires
qui ont des histoires parfois
excessivement dures je crois que si on
laisse l'adoption internationale et
l'adoption nationale parce que en France
aussi on a des enfants on a des pupilles
qui ont des histoires extrêmement
difficile on ne peut pas laisser ces
familles une fois que l'adoption est
prononcée se débrouiller seul on a
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de coca de
consultation d'orientation à l'adoption
qui sont dans les et proposé par des
médecins par des psychologues qui n'ont
aucune reconnaissance légale elles ne
dépendent que de la bonne volonté des
directeurs d'hôpitaux et des médecins et
je crois qu'il y a des CMPP qui le font
également il est indispensable
aujourd'hui effectivement d'avoir un
véritable accompagnement du début de du
début de la démarche jusque ensuite à
l'arrivée des enfant mais après qu'on a
on puisse avoir des ressources ces
enfants-là ont le droit et ces
familles-là ont le droit de trouver de
l'aide quand elles en ont besoin
concernant l'accès aux origines nous y
sommes absolument très sensibles à
enfance famille d'adoption euh nous
avons même organisé deux colloques l'un
en en 2012 et l'autre qui a eu lieu il y
a quelques jours sur effectivement cette
histoire cet accès à l'origine
euh comme l'a dit Cécile cet accès
appartient à l'adopter et à lui seul
c'est un droit ce droit lui est reconnu
mais c'est un droit qui est personnel la
relève de son intime certains ont besoin
de rechercher d'autres non certains ont
besoin tôt d'autres ont besoin beaucoup
plus tard certains ont juste besoin non
pas de retrouver une famille biologique
mais peut-être quand ils sont adoptés à
l'international de pouvoir aller voir
dans leur pays de voir d'où ils viennent
les odeurs le climat la langue
l'environnement ça peut suffire c'est
quelque chose qui leur appartient
véritablement il les parents adoptifs je
crois que nous ne sommes plus il y a 60
ans il y a 50 ans quand fa a été créé je
pense que il y a une énorme évolution
l'adoption aujourd'hui est beaucoup une
adoption visible euh on nous voit dans
la rue on nous voit au quotidien nos
enfants ne nous ressemblent pas mais ce
sont bien nos enfants et nous sommes
bien leurs parents je crois qu'il y a
aucun doute là-dessus mais en tout cas
le secret peut-être qu'il existe encore
je ne veux pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
encore des personnes peut-être j'ose
espérer que non mais en tout cas c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui qui est à mon
avis de l'ordre de 0,01 %. aujourd'hui
l'adoption est dite l'adoption est
racontée les parents à l'international
enfin je pense que Madame rillot et
Monsieur la cerne le diront également
euh entre autres dans les démarches
individuelles c'est nous parents qui
sommes dépositaires des dossiers des
enfants et c'est pour ça aussi qu'il
serait primordial que le knnaop qui a
été fait pour les enfants nés sous X en
France puisse être étendu à l'ensemble
des enfants adoptés avec un endroit où
il pourrait aller voir les dossiers ces
dossiers ils existent le service
d'adoption international quand il
délivre les visas a bien l'ensemble des
dossiers les oa en non mais tout ça est
éparpillé je crois que pour
effectivement euh permettre aux adoptés
quand ils le désirent de retrouver leurs
origines de retrouver leur histoire de
consulter leur dossier et peut-être
d'aller jusqu'à une éventuelle rencontre
avec leur famille d'origine je crois pas
que ça soit la réforme de l'adoption
pliniiaire qui soit qui soit la solution
mais bien la CR création d'un endroit
qui pourrait permettre effectivement à
ce que tous les dossiers soient archivés
à cet endroit-là et que quand quelqu'un
un adopté devenu adulte parce que je
rejoins Cécile je pense qu'il faut être
adulte pour pouvoir aller en tout cas
rechercher sa
famille puisse être accompagné et puisse
être
entendu dans sa demande les parents nous
sommes prêts à accompagner nos enfants
certains nous le demandent et puis
d'autres n'ont peut-être pas envie
d'être accompagnés par leurs parents
adoptifs ils ont peut-être besoin d'être
accompagnés mais par quelqu'un d'autre
alors je vais en profiter je vais vous
remettre le DVD qui nous avions fait
notre premier colloque le deuxième je me
permettrai de vous l'envoyer quand il
sortira et qui parle effectivement de
tout cet accompagnement de tous ces
dossier et que comment on ouvre un
dossier comment on accompagne un dossier
et ensuite comment on accompagne plus
loin voilà merci merci Madame pour vous
dire que ce que vous dites là
c'est-à-dire que so à un seul endroit
aux archives moi je pense c'est du
domaine réglementaire bon ça ça peut
faire donc je crois qu'on Michel tu
pourras peut-être hein dans le rapport
pour avis la comm sociale le dire et et
le demander au gouvernement tout de
suite parce que ça c'est c'est pas dans
la loi ça voilà c'est la demande qu'on a
fait dans notre communiqué que dont
parlait dont parlait Marc tout à
l'heure si vous avez rien à
dire vous dites je vais
merci je je je voudrais je voudrais
juste je je n'aurais pas grand chose à
rajouter sur ce cadis Cécile février ou
Nathalie Paron car je partage leur
opinion je voudrais simplement illustrer
le propos sur les dérives actuelles par
en signalant juste que pour maintenir un
un soi-disant lien biologique on arrive
à des choses assez ubuesques comme une
décision du tribunal de grande instance
de grenomble l'année dernière rendue
dans le cadre de l'adoption d'un enfant
haïtien où l'op tion plinière a été
refusée et l'adoption simple a été
signifiée a été proposée aux parents
alors qu'il n'y avait aucune filiation
connue en Haïti alors je veux bien qu'on
laisse le lien je veux bien qu'il ait
des idées sur le maintien du lien
biologique mais quand ce lien biologique
n'existe pas je voudrais savoir ce que
l'on a peur de rompre voilà c'est tout
c'est juste pour vous indiquer comment
de temps en temps avec des dispositions
idéologiques on arrive à des non sens
mettre l'autre vous pouvez
conclure bien je remercie je ne sais pas
si je vais conclure je voudrais euh
faire une remarque euh les questions que
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ont
posé euh
ne ne sont pas centrés sur ce qui était
l'objet de notre audition à savoir
l'adoption par les couples de même sexe
je crois vous l'avez bien signalé hein
que elle est entendue il y a des
avancées nécessaires à faire mais vous
avez plus insister sur l'adoption que ce
soit euh l'accès aux origines que ce
soit enfin différentes différents volets
je dirais de l'adoption ce qui montre
bien à l'évidence qu'il y a nécessité
d'une réforme de l'adoption qu'on ne
peut pas tout mélanger et que l'adoption
peut pas être une petite cerise qu'on va
mettre sur un gâteau dans la loi du
mariage pour tous il est absolument
nécessaire de reprendre le dossier de
reprendre le dossier de l'adoption je ne
rajouterai très rien sur ce qui a été
dit par sur l'accès aux origines je
crois que la voix des adoptés madame
février elle a mieux placer peut-être
pour en parler les OAS aussi ont quand
même un rôle important puisque nous
accompagnons dans le recherche de
dossiers nous accompagnons les jeunes
certains en ont besoin d'autres n'en ont
pas besoin mais je pense sincèrement que
les questions que vous avez posé mettre
en évidence la nécessité d'une réforme
de l'adoption et aussi du mesure de
protection et de projet pour les enfants
sur le sol français je vous remercie B
je voudrais peut-être passer la parole à
Madame de la cour qui la V Président si
elle veut ajouter ou conclure et Madame
Maisonneuve vous avez
encore non juste quelques secondes pour
reparler du du cas d'ïti simplement
puisque et déjà il y a plusieurs
centaines de familles qui sont
concernées par cette question d'adoption
simple qui leur est qui leur pourrait
leur être imposé par les tribunaux euh
effectivement les les familles
ressentent le besoin d'avoir un socle
solide pour construire le le le lien
adoptif et un socle juridique donc les
ces familles qui ont adopté en Haïti
depuis 2009 plus d'un millier euh se
retrouve dans l'embarras dans beaucoup
de cas il y a des disparités de statut à
l'intérieur des familles euh voilà donc
je voulais souligner ce point euh pas de
secret dans le cas des enfants haïtiens
100 % des enfants adoptés en Haïti
savent qu'ils sont adoptés qu'ils sont
originaires d'Haïti il n'y a pas de
secret évidemment et donc plutôt on le
rappelle constamment le le fait qu'ils
sont adoptés et nous avons à les
protéger et avoir un sucle solide pour
pouvoir leur assurer un développement
psychoaffectif le plus le plus
épanouissant évidemment je voudrais
rappeler que pour le knnaop
c'est bien et le le séisme qui a eu lieu
malheureusement en 2010 nous rappelle
que dans les pays d'origine il y a des
aléas de tous ordres qui peuvent menacer
les documents donc qu'il y ait
conservation de documents au knaop ça
serait vraiment quelque chose
d'absolument nécessaire voilà et donc
nous espérons aboutir bientôt à une
solution pour ces familles-l qui vivent
concrètement cette difficulté de statut
merci beaucoup mesdames monsieurs pour
cette audition ce matin je crois
qu'elles ont été très
utiles je ne pense pas que ça se
traduise par des amendements législatifs
parce que le législatif ça serait une
réforme complète de l'adoption et que
nous appellerons de nos vœux dans nos
rapports respectifs et peut-être dans
les dans les prises de parole qui auront
lieu et en tout cas peut-être de mesures
réglementaires que nous demanderons la
ministre notamment la ministre de la
Famille qui sera présente au
gouvernement en tout cas nous vous avons
bien entendu et avec Michel meunier vous
remercie beaucoup de de ce que vous nous
avez dit ce matin merci
merci donc nous allons poursuivre nos
auditions en écoutant d'abord monsieur
Tibau
colollin philosophe qui a publié
plusieurs ouvrages sur la question du
genre de
l'homosexualité et à qui je vais donner
la parole pour un posé liminire et
ensuite nous aurons peut-être des
questions à lui poser il nous répondra
nous avons en tout 1 heure maximum je
crois que ça peut suffire je vous en
prie
monsieuror oui je dois excuser le
président Jean-Pierre suur qui comme je
vous le disais à l'instant et ce matin
la conférence du consensus de Madame
tobira sur la récidive et cetera et qui
donc ne sera là je crois que cet
après-midi merci Monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je tenais tout d'abord d'abord
à vous exprimer la gratitude et
l'honneur que j'éprouve à présenter à
votre invitation mon point de vue sur ce
projet de loi objet de votre
réflexion celui-ci est porté par le
gouvernement au nom de l'égalité et ce à
double titre au nom de l'égalité de tous
les citoyens libres d'accéder au mariage
au nom de l'égalité de tous les enfants
de bénéficier des mêmes droits notamment
du droit à la
sécurité l'égalité étant une des valeurs
essentielles de notre République il
apparaît légitime de répondre
favorablement à une telle revendication
et de réparer la situation actuelle
considéré dès lors comme injuste c'est
en effet en prenant la justice comme
critère que le législateur délibère
comme le dit Montesquieu une chose n'est
pas juste parce qu'elle est loi mais
elle doit être loi parce qu'elle est
juste madame tobira dans son discours à
l'Assemblée nationale du 29 janvier 13
s'est employé à retracer l'histoire du
mariage civil depuis sa création en 1792
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour souligner à
quel point les conditions du mariage
avaient évolué l'axe de son
argumentation et que cette évolution
n'est pas aléatoire mais qu'elle répond
à une logique il y a bien un sens de
l'histoire du mariage la progressive
actualisation d'un germe inscrit en lui
dès sa création les valeurs de liberté
et d'égalité en rompant avec les règles
du mariage canonique la République
permettait à des gens jusque-là exclu du
mariage de se marier quel que soit son
métier ou sa religion tout citoyen
devait pouvoir librement se
marier de même l'inégalité de statut
constitutive de l'ordre familial tel que
le Code Napoléon le définissait a laissé
très progressivement place à une mise en
cohérence du droit de la famille avec
les valeurs de la démocratie le projet
de loi soumis à votre délibération est
ainsi présenté comme l'accomplissement
de cette logique d'intégration de ceux
qui jusqu'alors étaient exclus du
mariage celui-ci deviendrait alors une
institution véritablement universelle je
cite les saut les les les les paroles de
Madame gardesso une une institution
véritablement universelle réalisant les
promesses d'émancipation contenu dans la
Déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme est-il possible de
critiquer une telle présentation et
surtout à l'ône de quel critère il
paraît difficile à un citoyen
normalement constitué de remettre en
cause une loi se présentant ou un projet
de loi se présentant comme l'application
nécessaire des principes
républicains toute critique d'une telle
relecture historique risque d'être
soupçonné de transiger plus ou moins
consciemment avec le principe de laïcité
en effet seul semble-t-il celui qui
conserverait une conception sacrale du
mariage d'inspiration religieuse
pourrait impunément persévérer à en
interdire l'accès à certains citoyens le
sacré est compris ici comme ce qui est
soustrait à la délibération politique
invoquer une norme sacrée dans une
délibération démocratique se déployant
dans le champ de l'autonomie semble être
une attitude contradictoire
comme le dit clairement le sociologue
Eric Fassin je cite l'enjeu des
controverses actuelles c'est le statut
des normes dans les sociétés
démocratiques aujourd'hui les normes
sont-elles jamais définies d'une manière
qui transcende l'histoire sur un
principe tel que Dieu ou la tradition
avec une majuscule la nature ou la
culture voire la science c'est mots dans
le texte d'éc Fassin à chaque fois une
majuscule ou bien ces normes sont-elles
toujours immanente à l'histoire définie
par la délibération démocratique et la
négociation politique les normes
sont-elles jamais naturelles ou bien
est-ce toujours la société qui
s'autodéfinit bref continue Eric Fassin
dans des sociétés démocratiqu les normes
peuvent-elles encore ne pas être
appréhendées comme des normes sociales
fin de la
citation la loi démocratique apparaît
ainsi comme l'objectivation de l'État
social et mental à un moment de
l'histoire c'est pour cette raison que
la législation évolue l'histoire et les
sciences sociales deviennent dans cette
optique les grandes auxiliaires du
travail législatif ici même il y a
quelques semaines ou quelques jours iren
Terry vous a d'ailleurs exposé en quoi
cette ouverture du mariage et de
l'adoption au couple de personnes de
même sexe épouser une logique historique
de fond et que ce qui était impensable
il y a encore quelques années était
devenu aujourd'hui pensable à la suite
d'Eric il considère donc comme synonyme
normes démocratique et normes
construes mais dire qu'une norme est
construite signifie-t-il qu'elle est
immédiatement
démocratique il est clair qu'une loi est
le fruit d'un acte de la volonté du
législateur qui se détermine sous ce
rapport- là toute norme démocratique est
trivialement
construite mais la question est alors
sur quoi le législateur s'appuie-t-il
pour construire établir
telle ou telle norme sur sur tel sujet
éc Fassin considère qu'une norme ne peut
être démocratique que si elle est le
reflet de l'état social et non pas
l'application d'un principe externe à la
société Dieu la nature et ce la mesure
guidant le discernement devient alors ce
que l'on estime être le degré
d'acceptation d'une loi par la majorité
du corps social une telle conception ne
réduit-elle pas le travail du
législateur à être la chambre d'enregist
ement de revendication ayant acquis une
audience suffisante pour apparaître
comme pensable et donc
légitime dans ce type d'approche il
semble que la chose juste ne soit plus
vue comme l'objet d'une quête
rationnelle contrairement à ce que
soutient Montesquieu dans la phrase cité
plus haut on pourrait objecter à ma
critique à mon questionnement que
justement madame tobira loin de suivre
une voix disons sociologique et entre
guillemets immanentiste a au contraire
privilégié la voix des principes de
justice c'est bien au nom de l'égalité
et de la liberté de tous les citoyens
que ce projet de loi est soumis à votre
approbation dans ce cas il faut examiner
l'usage qui est fait du principe
d'égalité madame tobira a suggéré qu'il
était possible de faire une analogie
entre la situation des protestants ou
des Juifs face au mariage canonique
avant la Révolution et les homosexuels
face au mariage civil jusqu'à
aujourd'hui cette cette analogie pardon
est-elle
recevable avant la Révolution l'église
étant en charge de l'état civil les
règles constitutif du sacrement de
mariage ont des effets civils excluant
par là certaines catégories de personnes
du droit de fonder une famille la
création du mariage civil remédie à un
tel dysfonctionnement au titre que le
mariage a une consistance propre
indépendamment de sa dimension
sacramentelle qui ne concerne pas la
République naissante
le présupposé des révolutionnaires puis
de Portalis fortement d'ailleurs ici
inspiré de Rousseau et donc que le
mariage est une réalité inhérente à
l'humanité de l'homme quelle que soit sa
croyance religieuse à forceuré quel que
soit son métier en effet le consentement
réciproque et sens du contrat est le
fruit de la liberté individuelle et la
naissance des enfants relève de l'ordre
naturel de la transmission de la vie le
mariage civil ne s'adosse donc pas ordre
surnaturel mais un ordre humain perçu
comme antérieur aux coutumes et aux
conventions
humaines alors que les convictions
religieuses sont particulières et sous
ce rapport là peuvent être identifié à
des conventions particulière l'ordre
humain lui est universel puisqu'il est
fondé sur le partage d'une commune
humanité c'est ce que rappelle dans son
liminire la Déclaration des droits de
1789 je cite les représentant du peuple
français ont résolu d'exposer dans une
déclaration solennelle les droits
naturels inaliénables et sacré de
l'homme afin que cette déclaration
constamment présente à tous les membres
du corps social leur rappelle sans cesse
leur droits et leur
devoirs la religion et le métier ne sont
donc pas des critères pertinents au
regard de l'essence du mariage et au
regard des biens qui sont engagés de
manière
constitutive peut-on considérer comme le
soutient madame tobira que les
homosexuels sont aujourd'hui exclus du
mariage civil de la même manière que les
comédiens et les protestants ou les
Juifs avant la révolution pour soutenir
une telle proposition il faut manifester
que le mariage civil tel qu'il existe
encore aujourd'hui est réservé aux aux
hétérosexuels comme le mariage canonique
était réservé aux catholiques bref la
question est se marie-t-on en tant
qu'hétérosexuel l'hétérosexualité estit
une règle constitutive du mariage si tel
est le cas le principe d'égalité aurait
été appliqué depuis 200 ans un peu plus
de manière biaisée il aurait recellé un
point aveugle là où les révolutionnaires
considérrait que le mariage civil était
enfin ouvert à tous les citoyens et à
toutes les citoyennes il faudrait en
fait révéler un impensé en lire et lire
pardon en filigrane citoyens et
citoyenne
hétérosexuelle un peu comme le suffrage
universel a d'abord été universel au
sein d'une assiette singulièrement
rétrécie à la seule jante masculine
universalité divisée par 2 l'enjeu est
donc de réfléchir sur l'assiette à
laquelle le principe d'égalité doit
s'appliquer sous quel rapport se
marie-t-on
est-ce en tant qu'homme ou en tant que
femme ou bien est-ce en tant
qu'hétérosexuelle jusqu'à aujourd'hui et
en enfin demain également peut-être en
tant
qu'homosexuel certains militants LGBT
construisent une continuité dans les
lutte contre le racisme le sexisme et ce
qu'il nomme
l'hétérosexisme de même que l'égalité
des droits politiques a pu être appliqué
aux hommes sous le rapport exclusif de
leur appartenance par exemple à la race
blanche ou aux êtres humains sous le
rapport exclusif de leur appartenant de
leur appartenance au sexe masculin de
même l'égalité face au mariage a été
appliqué selon eux selon un schème
restrictif par le biais duquel était
discriminés tous ceux auxquels ont
refusé d'appliquer ce schème ainsi bien
que les personnes ayant une orientation
homosexuelle et toujours pu se marier
elle ne le pouvait pas en tant
qu'homosexuelle le degré
d'intériorisation d'un tel schème était
le pendant et la conséquence impensée
d'un système articulant savoir pouvoir
pratique institution vocabulaire toutes
choses qui ont été largement travaillé
par le philosophe Michel foucot donc la
conséquence impensée d'un système que
ces victimes ont fini par nommer
l'idéologie hétérosexiste ou en autre
terme
l'hétéronormativité objectivation qui
est simultanément désir d'émancipation
d'où la récurrence des arguments
rhtoriques qui sont utilisés pour
signifier que le mariage pour tous entre
en résonance avec l'abolition de
l'esclavage la lutte des Noirs
américains pour les droits civics ou
encore la libération des femmes de leurs
conditions
assujetti face à une telle lecture
tendant à créer une identité essentielle
entre diverses luttes le progressisme
comme sens immanant de l'histoire de
rechef je repose la question sous quel
rapport se marie-t-on il s'agit alors
d'identifier ce qui au regard de
l'essence du mariage et principe de
détermination de son assiette il s'agit
de saisir ce qui dans l'ESS du mariage
détermine le rapport sous lequel un
individu contracte un mariage comme l'a
déclaré iren Terry au moment des débats
sur le Pax
voilà un peu moins de 15 ans le mariage
est l'institution qui articule ou qui
était pensé comme articulant la
différence des sexes et la différence
des générations une telle approche
permet de saisir que le mariage articule
conjugalité et
filiation quel est le foyer d'un tel
noage pourrait dire entre conjugalité et
filiation sur quoi le législateur a-t-il
cherché à étayer la construction
juridique qui est le mariage civil de
manière à en déterminer les conditions
objectives l'âge le consentement la
différence des sexes la monogamie
l'absence de lien de parenté la réponse
est bien évidemment que le référent
choisi pour penser cette articulation a
été la transmission de la vie humaine
par l'union sexuelle d'un homme et d'une
femme acceptant en amont d'assumer la
charge de l'éducation de cette nouvelle
personne certains affirment qu'une telle
construction juridique de la famille
correspond à un idéal situé
historiquement qui dans la pratique
connaît toutes sortes de transgressions
et ceux de plus en plus et qui de plus
est discriminant envers ceux qui n'y ont
pas accès en l'occurrence les
homosexuels à ce titre une telle
construction doit être réformée pour
accueillir d'autres possibilités quelle
serait alors la logique de ce nouvel
agencement le présupposé que nous avons
nommé plus haut et que l'on se mariait
jusqu'alors comme
hétérosexuel c'est donc aussi comme
hétérosexuel que l'on pouvait prétendre
être parents alors même que certains
étaient en fait homosexuels il s'agit
dès lors de sortir de l'hypocrisie et
pour cela il s'agit de mettre à bas
l'hétéronormativité dont la clé de voûte
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui le Code civil
pourquoi nous dit-on un homosexuel ne
pourrait-il pas être parent non pas
malgré son homosexualité mais en tant
qu'il est homosexuel la réponse évidente
jugé hétérosexiste par certains est que
c'est impossible à contrario la
sociologue Virginie descoutur déclare je
cite la norme
hétérosexuelle pose que deux personnes
du même sexe ne peuvent faire un enfant
puisque le couple formé est forcément
stér
donc engendré en étant homo et perçu
comme contre natureat cela équivaut à un
interdit de maternité pour les
lesbiennes et de de paternité pour les
Gay fin de la citation si l'on comprend
bien cette citation deux hommes ou deux
femmes ne peuvent avoir un enfant non
pas parce que c'est impossible mais
parce que c'est jusqu'à maintenant
interdit discriminatoire d'où la
discrimination notons que le présupposé
d'un interdit et qu'il a pour objet ce
qui justement possible on n'interdit
jamais ce qui est impossible donc pour
que le discours de Virginie des coutures
a un sens il est nécessaire de changer
la signification l'acception des
expressions faire un enfant et engendrer
il faut abandonner l'enracinement
charnel et le remplacer par une
détermination de la volonté faire un
enfant c'est dans ce texte le concevoir
ça renvoie la notion de projet parental
le concevoir en formuler explicitement
la volonté et prendre les moyens pour
réaliser cette conception soit
l'adoption soit la l'assistance médicale
la procréation soit la gestation pour
autr c'est bien la procréation naturelle
prise comme référence qui permettait de
déduire les condition objectiv du
mariage or on retrouve dans la
revendication actuelle la confirmation
que la conjugalité et l'affiliation sont
liés mais le principe de cette liaison
ne peut pe plus être le référent de la
procréation naturelle une fois que l'on
s'en est séparé par quoi la remplacer
qu'est-ce qui va remplacer ce référent
naturel pour penser cette articulation
entre conjugalité et
filiation les volontés contractuelles
des individus quel que soit le leur
orientation sexuelle la volonté était
bien sûr auparavant nécessaire mais non
pas suffisante puisqu'elle ne pouvait se
réaliser que par la médiation de la
sexualité procréatrice notons que
jusqu'à maintenant l'assistance médicale
la procréation et l'adoption sont pensé
et organisé selon ce même référent mais
si la volonté devient le principe
premier de l'articulation au nom
dearticulation entre conjugalité et
filation au nom de quoi garder les
autres conditions elles aussi déduites
de l'éayage sur la procréation pourquoi
garder par exemple la monogamie on
pourrait très bien dire que jusqu'à
maintenant seul les monogames ont pu se
marier
et que les polygames ont donc été
discriminés puisqu'ils n'ont pas pu se
marier qu'ils n'ont pu se marier qu'en
niant leur désir polygame on voit par là
que si la volonté devient le critère et
l'unique critère si elle devient à
elle-même sa propre boussole seu une
volonté peut limiter une autre volonté
mais ne serait-ce pas justement le rôle
du législateur que de limiter les
prétention des volontés certes mais sur
quel critère va-t-il se tourner pour
discerner ou fixer la limite si tout
référent antérieur a été congédié comme
non démocratique parce que n'étant pas
construit par les hommes eux-mêmes confè
la citation d'éc Fassin mais ayant un
statut de norme sacré que reste-t-il à
la raison à considérer pour déterminer
ce qui est juste rien et juste ce que la
volonté du législateur décide de
déclarer juste et juste toute
revendication présentée au titre de
l'égalité indépendamment d'un examen du
contenu conc
si tel est le cas l'idée même de
délibération législative devient veine
et je pourrais de manière un peu
cavalière dire et je vous fais perdre
votre temps en cherchant à éclairer
votre jugement bref si tel est le cas il
est préférable que nous levions notre
séance de travail je vous remercie de
votre
attention merci
beaucoup
alors madame
Menier oui
difficile et ben non merci de nous avoir
permis de nous élever comme ça c'est
vrai euh vous avez aussi dans votre
propos et dans votre intervention invité
pas mal de monde notamment monsieur Éric
Fassin donc merci ça neous fait quelque
part aussi peut-être je ne sais pas je
je ne pense pas il aurait pu en tout cas
par votre bouche il était invité ce
matin donc sur euh oui tout ce que vous
nous avez dit mais ce qui aussi le
législateur bah c'est le principe de
réalité donc sans parler de dichotomie
et de grand écart c'est vrai que vos
propos nous éclairent sûrement mais la
réalité existante de ces familles
existantes de ces couples qu'on dit
maintenant homosexuel mais avant on
disait pas couple hétérosexuel hein donc
voilà euh nous fait à nous législateur
le devoir de prendre en compte et et de
délibérer sur un projet de loi de
mariage pour les couples de personnes de
même sexe donc j'ai pas vraiment de de
question et j'en suis navrée pour le
moment mais en tout cas merci pour votre
on voit la perversité du philosophe mais
sur tout à l'heure comment oui moi je la
perversité puisque il ne conclut pas
tout en donnant des arguments pour et
contre mais finalement plutôt
contre mais moi ma position c'est que ce
qui est juste c'est ce que dit la loi
voilà c'est tout et la loi elle ne se
réfère pas à un ordre naturel elle se
réfère à un rapport de force à un moment
donné et et point final ah oui donc le
le fondement du juste c'est le rapport
de force moi c'est c'est mon point de
vue c'est le point de vue marxiste de la
loi d'accord monsieur ça le mérite de la
clarté vous comprendrez monsieur con que
je ne suis pas du tout sur la même ligne
que ou oui ou oui d'abord la loi c'est
l'expression de la volonté générale et
pas de la la volonté de quelques-uns
parce que ce que vous avez dit à la fin
c'est à partir du moment où une demande
et que c'est possible il faut accepter
et et le problème du législateur dans
tous les domaines dans tous les domaines
c'est certainement pas ça ça n'est et on
pourrait donner de de multiples exemples
les choses interdites ça fait le code
pénal tout n'est pas autorisé bah oui
non mais et donc tout n'est pas permis
aujourd'hui sauf pour des raisons
médical de stérilité en France la
procréation le l'assistance médicale à
la procréation est interdite de même que
les les ce qu'on appelle la gestation
pour
autrui s'il y a des demandes et comme ça
existe ailleurs parce que c'est ce qu'on
nous dit un petit peu il faut l'accepter
parce qu'il y a des réalités et même
ceux qui ont alors évidemment parce que
c'est c'est plus compliqué que pour
d'autres choses parce qu'il y a des
enfants il y a des enfants qui qui sont
issu de ces de ces pratiques interdites
aujourd'hui par la loi mais est-ce que
c'est pour ça qu'il faut accepter moi je
disant le moinsdisant éthique parce
queil y a quand même une question
d'éthique derrière il y a des questions
d'éthique et de bioéthique c'est
vraiment une question deuxième question
vous n'avez pas du tout évoqué et moi je
suis extrêmement
préoccupé de
l'invasion dans notre pensée enfin dans
la pensée de certains sans le dire de la
théorie du genre parce que souvent et
j'entends des propos quelquefois même
quand j'ai bien lu les les propos de
certains parlementaires ils sont adeptes
de la théorie du
genre et là c'est une
théorie je sais pas si elle est
philosophique monsieur mais est-ce que
vous pensez parce que cette théorie est
extrêmement dangereuse puisque la
différence des sexes et cetera tout ça
ont choisit son donc il y a plus il y a
plus de sens et d'ailleurs au
nom
originairement d'une théorie
révolutionnaire ou d'un marxisme
appliqué à la domination de l'homme sur
la femme c'est ça l'origine des
penseuses
essentiellement penseuses américaine
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer
est-ce que vous pensez pas qu'il y a une
influence de C théories sur le le projet
tel qu'il est ou tel qu'il viendra merci
jean-jqu comme nous sommes plutôt dans
la réflexion que dans les vraies
questions je vais demander si d'autres
collègues
souhaitent dé poser des question ah oui
mais bon euh est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
collègues qui souhaitent s'exprimer
maintenant bon alors voilà vous avez le
temps de alors bon peut-être ça sur la
théorie du genre il y a c'est un sujet
très complexe d'abord
il y a pas la théorie du genre il y a
une
approche à partir des des sciences
sociales de la différence entre le
masculin et le féminin et la mise en
évidence évidemment que la manière de
vivre sa masculinité ou sa féminité est
en partie conditionné par notre culture
par par nos coutumes nos habitudes et
cetera à partir de là donc qui qui on
pourrait dire une une l'objet propre des
SCI sociale qui est effectivement de
repérer la la contingence des
différentes manières de de vivre sa
masculinité sa féminité aussi bien dans
l'histoire que que dans la géographie ce
que l'on constate immédiatement à à
partir de là évidemment on peut avoir
une une lecture plus radicale
de de cette approche de genre comme là
pour le coup certains philosophes ou
certaines
philosophes le font notamment à partir
de de Michel fouco entre autres qui
effectivement considère
que il y a un donné biologique malâ
femelle encore que Judit Butler va
jusqu'à contester d'ailleurs cette cette
distinction mais bon et puis que
effectivement la tout le reste est une
pure construction sociale alors
évidemment ça ça rentre en interférence
avec notamment notre sujet puisque on
retrouve galement la problématique que
j'ai essayé de traiter peut-être de
manière perverse mais euh comment dire
parce que je voulais justement pas
arriver je voulais plutôt soulever des
enjeux plutôt que juste parce que je
pense qu'il y a déjà tellement eu de
choses qui ont été dites sur ce sujet
pour compte que les arguments sont déjà
assez balayés j'ai essayé de de prendre
une approche un peu transversale pour
rendre un service philosophique même si
j'ai ma position qui est de fait assez
claire il me semble que derrière
justement mon propos c'était la la
question du constructivisme en fait euh
or moi il me semble fondamentalement que
même
si le législateur doit prendre en compte
la réalité sociale et notamment donc
certaines revendications certaines
souffrances la question est de savoir si
pour honorer on pourrait dire
les la gestion entre guillemets ou
l'accompagnement de
certaines difficulté notamment ici par
exemple une certaine précarité il est
nécessaire de modifier fondamentalement
les règles du jeu si l'on peut dire et
de de créer donc quelque chose de de
radicalement nouveau et et et il me
semble que si on entre dans cette
optique on considère donc que par
exemple le fait d'être père et mère est
une une pure construction sociale et que
finalement pour un enfant ce qui est
important
c'est pas tant d'avoir un père et une
mère que d'avoir deux adultes mais
pourquoi deux plutôt que trois pourquoi
pourquoi pas bon deux adultes que ces
deux adultes soient des femmes ou des
hommes finalement et là effectivement
quand François singli dit finalement moi
je je veux pas que ça soit deux par à
l'époque vous savez enfin il y a
quelques semaines certains disaient on
va supprimer dans le Code civil le
notion de père et mère on va remplacer
par un par en a et par en B ou je sais
plus bon et François de singli avait
fait une tribune dans Le Monde que vous
avez sûrement lu non non pas du tout il
faut absolument que dans la loi il y ait
père- mère puisque et queon puisse dire
qu'un enfant a deux pères et deux mères
et il tenait évidemment dans sa logique
constructiviste absolument à à à ce ce
type d'expression ce qui implique
évidemment que euh on considère ici que
l'enfant euh euh ce n'est pas un bien
pour l'enfant que de vivre dans la
continuité de de son origine et que l'on
considère et ça c'est un des présupposés
de la théorie constructiviste qu'on
retrouve dans certaines lectures de du
genre on considère que le biologique est
de
l'infrahumain d'ailleurs on dit du
biologique moi je parle jamais de
biologique je parle de l'unité de la
personne sexuée mon corps n'est pas une
valise que je transporte avec moi c'est
je suis mon corps et que mon corps est
sexué et que donc ma présence auprès de
d'une personne et et et sexué et et que
c'est pas juste mon corps biologique vu
comme inf humain à forceorie comme
producteur de gamettes ou ou de
matériaux qui peut intéresser simplement
les relations humaine et donc il me
semble que
là effectivement il y a une une
correspondance profonde entre le le le
sujet qui que sur lequel vous
travailleez en ce moment et une certaine
approche radicale de de du genre où
effectivement comment dire le le le le
don le fameux donné naturel madame
tobira a fini le débat parlementaire en
disant enfin on est passé au-delà de la
nature mais évidemment si on comprend la
nature comme un ordre biologique
infraahumain bien sûr comme nous sommes
tous des êtres humains nous ne
souhaitons que d'une chose c'est c'est
c'est de vivre en dehors de ce qui est
infraumain c'est c'est mais je je vais
dire c'est bien naturel mais quand je
dis c'est bien naturel ça veut dire
naturel au sens de ce qui est propre à
mon humanité c'estàdire ce qui
correspond aux
aspirations de ma personne dans unité de
ma personne et donc là il me semble pour
pour pas être trop long mais il me
semble
que le le le au nom effectivement d'une
d'une recherche de sécurisation par
exemple de certains liens familiaux ou
de certaines situation de vie
actuelle on cherche à élaborer un tout
autre
modèle donc je pense que c'est important
déjà d'en avoir pleinement conscience
tout autre modèle qui en fait va aboutir
à des à des situations similaires parce
que la logique que j'ai essayé de
développer va engendrer par exemple la
possibilité que pour une femme seule
d'accéder à la procréation des calé
c'est bien sûr pas encore dans la loi
mais c'est la logique intrinsèque de ce
que nous voyons or si une femme peut
accéder à la procration méicalement
assistée cuid de l'argument que l'on
entend aujourd'hui de dire aujourd'hui
il y a des enfants qui sont en
souffrance ou qui sont disons en danger
parce que si leur père légal ou leur
mère légale Meur bah le ils sont ils
sont ils sont à la rue ce qui est
évidemment faux mais donc donc il y a
une inquiétude qui est tout à fait
légitime mais donc en fait à partir du
moment où le seul critère devient la
volonté encore une fois moi il me semble
alors je me situe au niveau des principe
et j'entends bien que la réalité mais je
pense qu'il y a d'autres manières de
prendre en compte cette réalité et que
le rôle notamment du juge enfin de la
justice et au cas par cas de vérifier et
de statuer sur l' intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant et que là vous avez un rôle de
législateur infiniment plus déterminant
puisque vous vous installez on pourrait
dire une nouvelle manière enfin les
règles du jeu entre guillemets et et
donc une une nouvelle manière de
comprendre de comprendre
l'affiliation et et et ça je pense que
c'est évidemment un enjeu qui mérite bah
ce que vous êtes en train de faire
évidemment ici un débat approfondi et
euh dont il faut bien me semble-t-il
mesurer la logique jusqu'au bout parce
que on peut dire nous on s'arrête là et
cetera effectivement le législateur peut
dire les rapports de force ne sont pas
pour l'instant
mais dans ce cas-là il faut
effectivement être lucide sur les
conséquences ultimes qui une fois qu'on
a comment dire je sais plus qui disaitin
on peut pas quitter la révolution comme
on quitte un comme on saute d'un tramoué
j'ai cherché ch la référence mais je
rappelle plus mais bah il y a une
logique c'estàd une fois qu'on rentre
dans un processus on peut subjectivement
dire moi je veux pas plus loin mais de
fait on va plus loin alors ça peut
prendre un certain
temps bon y y a-t-il
d'autres Catherine
génissoni ce que tout à l'heure soyons
bien clair j'ai trouvé que votre façon
de de nous présenter les choses était
très intéressante justement parce que
vous pas en disant B je suis contre
machin tout ça bon voilà que vous avz un
certain nombre d'arguments voilà c'est
pas les mien mais ça me paraî
intéressant donc je vous remercie pour
ça ah ou
oui bah non mais toute façon on est ici
pour entendre tout aujourd'hui je dirais
on entend des choses intéressantes ça
pas toujours été le cas notamment
hier tu nétais pas là
euh Catherine
Genisson c'est c'est c'est d'abord merci
de votre propos oui qui qui interpelle
beaucoup c'est c'est c'est difficile de
poser des questions parce qu'on a
comment dire peur de d'avoir l'air très
bête oh non si si
euh je pense que vous indiquez que quand
même la norme sociale est fondamentale
pour
euh écrire la loi pour que que que le le
le législateur prenne ses
responsabilités et vous avez la question
enfin vous avez enfin si j'ai bien
compris indiquer que la question était
de savoir si le législateur était
suiviste finalement s'il
entérinait ou s'il était s'il avait une
fonction de de de de précurseur ce que
je pense aussi enfin il doit avoir je
pense que ça doit être un équilibre
entre les deux mais parce que sinon on
peut citer des exemples où par exemple
la loi banataire sur l'abolition de la
peine de mort hein c'était ou la loi sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
qui qui
madame veille a fait preuve grâce à une
partie de l'Assemblée nationale à
beaucoup de courage politique ça c'était
le la première chose qui m'avait
interpellé
et ce qui suppose aussi de fait à un
moment donné
comment
limitet-on enfin quel quel est quels
sont les critères limitatifs de la norme
parce queeffectiv enfin c'est d'ailleurs
un sujet qui est apparu de façon il faut
bien le reconnaître assez assez
lamentable dans le le politique à
l'Assemblée nationale parfois pas
toujours mais parfois mais néanmoins le
sujet est posé donc c'éit un petit peu
les Ben et en fait et derrière enfin
avec votre question effectivement c'est
ça qui est passionnant aussi dans ce
débat mais qui est un peu vertigineux
c'est que ce qui se joue aussi c'est le
le sens des mots en fait parce
que et et là effectivement les mots
renvoient un certain usage courant
mais en même
temps
justement comment dire si on dit bah
finalement la manière de de prendre des
mots ou de les utiliser indique
nécessairement que ce que signifi ces
mots renvoie des situations justes dans
ce cas-là évidemment il il y a plus
aucune aucun questionnement véritable
donc il me semble que justement le rôle
du législateur c'est de chercher la
justice et comme vous dites ça peut être
justement
ça peut permettre d'anticiper ou d'aller
contre des évolu enfin des des une une
pensée majoritaire mais ce qui manifeste
bien ici que justement il y a une quête
de de ce qui est juste et il me semble
que ce que j'ai essayé de te soulever
comme comme question comme problème
si en fait on dit tout est
construit le sacré forcément sacré au
sens de ce qui n'est pas disponible ce
qui est pas ce que l'on ne peut pas ce
qui n'est pas totalement malléable le
sacret est nécessairement lié euh à une
vision religieuse par exemple évidemment
dans une société enfin dans une
République laïque on va dire c'est c'est
c'est pas pertinent pour pour pour
raison assez évidente mais toute la
question est de savoir est-ce que Al
c'est pour ça que j'ai cité le le texte
préliminaire de de déclaration des
droits de l'homme qui utilise le mot
droit sacré alors les droits sacrés
évidemment ça implique quand même comme
présupposé que il y a un ordre humain
qui n'est pas
totalement dépendant de l'artifice
humain bien sûr qu'il est mis en œuvre
par les libertés humaines on est bien
d'accord par exemple quand la la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme parle
du droit de propriété bah le droit de
propriété bien sûr que il est mise en
forme par le législateur et que ça peut
évoluer mais ce que les constituants ont
essayé de dire c'est que
justement la propriété a aussi une
dimension naturelle pas au sens où on
trouverait des droits de propriété dans
la jungle bien sûr que non mais naturel
au sens que ça correspond à un ordre
humain que l'être humain peut découvrir
en lui par sa raison à partir d'un
questionnement de son expérience et que
et que justement par exemple une
législation qui
supprimerait le droit de propriété
serait une législation contraire aux
droits fondamentaux alors c'est un débat
qui a eu lieu notamment dans la question
juive de de Marx évidemment il critique
cette cette vision des dro des droits de
l'homme bon en l'occurrence la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme est
quand même le préambule de de notre
Constitution donc ça reste un texte bien
sûr opératoire pour pour pour vous enfin
pour pour nous tous citoyens donc ça
veut dire ici que néanmoins il y a me
semble-t-il un un référent qui n'est
évidemment pas un référent religieux
mais qui est un référent alors sacré
entre guillemets parce que pour nous le
mot sacré est tout de suite religieux
donc on va dire mais sacré au sens de
voilà qui n'est pas totalement malléable
à l'artifice humain et que bien sûr que
c'est dans la lumière de de ces
principes qui sont constitutifs de
l'ordre humain que le législateur doit
ensuite
évidemment on pourrait dire inventer des
normes concrètes parce que
évidemment invoquer un
principe ça ça règle pas la vie
quotidienne des gens ça on est on est
bien d'accord mais je pense que c'est
dans la lumière de ça or là il me semble
que euh sur la question qui nous occupe
finalement la revendication homosexuel
euh au mariage et à l'affiliation part
du principe que justement
euh comment dire euh le mariage a été
pensé de manière discriminatoire et
c'est c'est et c'est ça que je je je
justement que je je remets en cause que
je questionne parce que je pense que
justement on ne se marie pas en tant
qu'hétérosexuel on se marie en tant
qu'homme et femme parce que justement il
y a cette articulation alors vous allez
me dire oui mais aujourd'hui comme l'a
dit rine Terry l'autre jour énormément
d'enfants naissent hor mariage on est
bien d'accord euh beaucoup de gens
divorcent on est bien d'accord bon euh
il y a des techniques de procréation
médicalement assister qui manifeste
évidemment mais en même temps il me
semble que justement ultimement ce qui
se joue c'est euh de savoir s'il est
juste euh pour un enfant enf s'il est
juste pour un enfant de pouvoir se vivre
dans la continuité de sa double origine
et pas
simplement considérer que une des deux
origines c'est simplement des gamettes
qui qui son qui sortent dans sesou mais
et moi je repose la question dans
l'autre sens au nom de quoi au nom de
quel principe peut-on priver un enfant
délibérément
d'une d'un accès à une de ses doubles
origines quand bien même on est on est
tout à fait d'accord que il peut être
très bien éduqué soigné aimé par les
adultes qui s'occupe de lui donc pour
moi l'enjeu fondamental c'est pas tant
l'homoparentalité au sens de de comment
dire d'une d'une présence éducative de
soins auprès d'enfants c'est la question
de l'homophiliation et or justement
c'est un des enjeux de ce texte me
semble-t-il de créer une une conception
de l'affiliation non pas de
l'homophiliation comme telle mais pour
que l'homophiliation soit pensable il
faut dire la
l'affiliation le le devient fondé sur la
volonté uniquement sur la volonté des
adultes et moi je repose ma question si
c'est simplement la volonté des adultes
et et plus du tout le référent naturel
parce qu'il est ce référent naturel pris
comme modèle é est hétérosexiste alors
où mett-ons les limites alors vous allez
me dire comme je disais justement c'est
c'est vous allez me dire c'est à nous de
mettre les limites mais on va dire sont
des limites on les met là pourquoi pas
ailleurs ça devient arbitraire en fait
arbitraire au sens au sens strict
c'estàdah je décide d'aller jusque là
pourquoi pas plus loin bah parce que
voilà
alors moi pour moi en tout cas
philosophiquement ça me pose un
véritable problème oui
Catherine
oui il faut dire les nom Caine quand
même vous Avezé le le le sujet du couple
hétérosexuel qui a recours à la PMA
quelle différence y a-t-il
entre le couple hétérosexuel qui aour
recours avec avec la PMA à la PMA pardon
avec tout le sujet de effectivement d'un
moment donné de du problème de l'origine
aussi par rapport à un couple homosexuel
qui a recours à la PMA où il y a où il y
a cette notion de couple où il y a cette
notion de de de deux
personnes puisque il y a le sujet de de
comment dire que pose le recours à la
PMA avec tout le sujet que ça peut poser
à l'enfant de de de de la question de
son son son origine mais pourquoi
comment enfin là pour le coup pourquoi
euh et pourtant si je me pose la
question j'ai pas j'ai pas aujourd'hui
la réponse mais pourquoi faire une telle
différence entre un couple hétérosexuel
qui a recours à la pmama et un couple
homosexuel qui a recours à la PMA par
rapport à l'enfant parce que pour
l'enfant sauf à dire sauf à dire
qu'effectivement même si tout le monde
euh dit au éclair que l'amour l'amour de
du FO enfin l'amour du foyer l'amour du
couple c'est ce qui a de fondamental
pour l'enfant enfin c'est ce qui se dit
quand même de enfin c'est ce que ça
chacun revendique de plus en plus
largement aujourd'hui
euh je pense que le sujet de l'origine
se pose peut se posé pour l'enfant de la
même façon dans un couple hétérosexuel
qui a eu recours à la PMA que dans un
couple homosexuel
alors la première distinction c'est
évidemment le comment dire le le sens de
l'adverbe médicalement donc on
présuppose que le le sens de de de de
procréation médicalement assistée donc
le présupposé d'ailleurs c'est le c'est
la vie que va rendre le le CCNE d'ici la
fin de l'année est-ce que donc la PMA a
été pensée évidemment comme traitement
d'une pathologie qui est la stérilité
donc évidemment ça présuppose certaines
conditions euh disons objective d'accès
euh mais je je suis tout à fait d'accord
le le le le le comment dire la
procréation médicalement assistée avec
donneur anonyme il y a
des me semble-il met dans une situation
problématique et d'ailleurs de plus en
plus se pose la question de cette quête
de l'origine d'ailleurs c'est un des
enjeux peut-être de la réforme de la loi
de la famille mais là encore
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on fait peser
finalement sur l'enfant on va dire bien
sûr qu'il a le droit à l'accès à ses
origines mais dans ce cas-là il va
devoir peu à peu comment
dire
porter cette cette origine complexe
alors Dieu merci c'est tout à
fait comment dire ça peut se vivre de
manière tout à fait harmonieuse et
cetera mais il me semble que
effectivement ça se pose déjà donc avec
la PMA avec l'AD la sémination avec
d'honneur anonyme et
que dans le cas de la PMA pour des
couples de de
femmes ce qui est renforcé à forciorie
évidemment c'est le fait que comment
dire il y a plus d'analogie avec on
quitte le modèle analogique d'où le fait
qu'on puisse plus parler de médical
enfin de médecine qui puisque c'est pas
une stérilité alors je sais que Daniel
borillo parle de de stérilité sociale
mais ça c'est un néologisme pour moi
éminemment problématique
oui on va l'entendre ce soir donc ah ben
très bien vous aurez un autre son de
cloche on a beaucoup de son de cloche
oui oui je pense que Catherine dernier
mot nous oui non mais je veux pas prer
la parole sur d'autres le le le comment
dire le sujet de l'anonyisation pas du
don dans le cadre de la p était un sujet
d'ailleurs de qui a été largement
discuté dans la révision des lois de
biothique des dernières révisions de LO
biotiqu et pour lesquelles finalement on
n'a pas on est resté sur l'existance
j'ai envie de dire bon mais ça je crois
que c'est un sujet central bon vous
avait indiqué qu'un couple qui
hétérosexuel qui a recours à la PMA
c'est bien évidemment le sujet de la
stérilité stérilité médicale mais là en
fait on fait effectivement
euh la différence à juste titre entre
une stérilité médicale et une
stérilité comment on peut dire sexuel
enfin bon bon et dans le même temps ce
que je comprends pas si si vous voulez
c'est que dans le même temps on tout le
enfin de plus en plus on entend mais
sujet c'est pas qu'il y ait de pèr de
mère toute façon à partir du moment où
il y a la cellule familiale c'est
formidable pour l'enfant c'est ça que je
comprends pas si vous voulez c'est que
autant je pense qu'il peut il il y a de
vraies question pour l'enfant parce que
ce qui compte quand même dans dans dans
toutes ces questions là c'est le sujet
de de l'enfant me semble-t-il et qu'
autant qu'on puisse se poser la question
du du problème de l'origine c'est c'est
c'est légitime ou alors il faut avoir le
courage de dire enfin le courage il faut
reconnaître qu'on n pas qu'on qu'on
n'accepte pas l'argument de dire que le
le
le le constat de de l'absence d'altérité
sexuelle est un vrai sujet pour
l'enfant on on commence à banaliser
cette questionl parce que enfin pas pas
banaliser mais je dire à accepter ce
principe de
nonalérité et en même temps on base
quand même le raisonnement sur la enfin
le constat de cette ê non altérité par
rapport à ce que vous dites oui mais moi
justement il me semble que ce qui rend
pensable l'absence enfin le caractère
légitime de de cette absence d'altérité
c'est effectivement que à partir du
moment où considère que l'homme et la
femme sont interchangeables évidemment
la
présence de la mère et la présence du
père sont vu à peu près comme
équivalente et donc ce que l'on retient
c'est finalement simplement la quantité
de il faut être deux mais à partir du
moment où on quitte
l'articulation que j'ai essayé de de
rappeler pourquoi on garde le le de
pourquoi on garde nécessèrement de alors
on va dire bah parce que c'est une
demande qui est faite par des couples
d'accord mais qu'est-ce qu'on fera quand
il y aura des demandes qui peuvent déjà
exister la comparentalité ça existe déjà
donc quand quand il y a quatre ou C
adultes qui participe à un projet
parental bah vous rendez bien compte ici
que ça fait peser me semble-t-il sur sur
sur l'enfant l'enfant devient principe
d'unité effectivement de de de d'une
convergenence de de volonté d'adultte
qui peuvent être évidemment très bien
intentionné il s'agit pas du tout de de
juger le leurs intentions mais il me
semble ici que dans ce cas-là évidemment
on conçoit un enfant mais conception au
sens de de de travail de l'ingénierie
hein on conçoit et effectivement pour
concevoir quelque chose on peut être
plusieurs on peut être un certain nombre
mais là il me semble que dans cette
logique voilà le le le le critère n'est
plus opératoire en
fait merci moi j'ai une une question à
vous poser mais qui est peut-être est-ce
que du point de vue du philosophe
euh qu'est-ce que vous dites sur le nom
sur le mot voilà est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a des mots
identifiants dont on ne peut pas changer
de sens
mariage père mère oui moi je pense que
il y a des mots qui
euh alors on peut on peut très bien dire
bah de fait si la loi est votée demain
ça va changer donc on peut constater
effectivement qu' mais moi moi je
répondrai en disant bah oui mais le
langage comme il est on en fait usage on
peut on peut on faire un usage justement
en progressivement changeant le sens et
en manipulant le sens moi mais moi il me
semble que justement ce que j'essaie de
montrer c'est que certains mots
renvoient ultimement à ce que ce que
notre raison découvre dans une réalité
humaine en l'occurrence ici un un
agancement de liens humains parce que
mariage filiation tout ça c'est c'est
c'est des des relations constiut enfin
des relations différents types de
relations que des êtres humains peuvent
avoir et qu' me semble que ces
relations bien sûr qu'elles peuvent être
assumé et vécu différemment dans les
sociétés mais qu'elles ont elles
renvoient tous toutes pardon en
l'occurrence ici à une une réalité qui
est antérieure en fait à la volonté
humaine et à la raison humaine et c'est
parce qu'elle est antérieur pas
chronologiquement mais fondamentalement
que justement la raison peut essayer de
l'objectiver et que et que donc le sens
de ces mots a effectivement quelque
chose d'essentiel alors alors évidemment
j'ai bien conscience que lorsqu'on
raisonne de manière on pourrait dire à
partir de la réalité de l'usage social
et dans un mouvement qui valorise le
devenir historique on va dire votre
conception est est purement déconnecté
idéal mais il me semble que il y a on
pourrait dire une sorte de résistance
interne du réel et que cette résistance
interne de relle lorsque finalement on
veut passer outre elle elle a des
conséquences très concrètes dans la
manière de vivre les relations les uns à
travers les autres moi il me semble que
justement ça engendre de
l'injustice alors puisqu'on a encore 3
minutes vous avez cité iren Terry bon
qu'est-ce que vous dites de la du point
de vue du philosophe sur le discours
anthropologique notamment de Madame
héritier qui nous a dit bah écoutez euh
les sociétés depuis qu'on les connaît
pratiquement ont passé des
compromis les uns derrière les autres et
c'est ce que nous allons faire en
sachant très bien que bientôt il y en
aura d'autres et notamment elle a évoqué
la possibilité de faire naître des
enfants extrautérus
oui en terme de
description je je je men remets à sa
science qui est qui est grande donc ça
que qu'on puisse constater que les
sociétés ont passé toutes sortes de
compromis et et la nôtre oui mais je
repose ma question qui qui a un onle
philosophique de de de philosophie
pratique bah est-ce que tous les
compromis sont justes pour moi c'est ça
la véritable question parce que on peut
aussi constater dans l'histoire que
certains compromis se sont révélés
injustes donc justement parce qu'ils
ét en fait déterminé par des rapports de
force et que justement les rapports de
force euh peuvent ne pas être toujours
justes bien sûr alors ça vous permet de
faire une belle conclusion sauf si vous
avez encore TR mots à nous dire non ben
je vous remercie de de l'attention que
vous avez porté à à mon propos non mais
c'est bien alors nous avons le grand
honneur de recevoir Madame Sylviane
agazensski qui comme vous le savez est
une philosophe qui a écrit beaucoup de
livres a beaucoup œuvré pour euh faire
évoluer la pensée tout simplement pour
penser sur ces questions qui nous
occupent et bien d'autres donc vous nous
faites beaucoup d'honneur d'être venu au
Sénat il y a des collègues qui n'ont pas
pu venir notamment pour la raison que
j'ai expliqué d'autres encore puisque la
maison travaille beaucoup hein et donc
si vous en étiez d'accord vous pourriez
nous faire un exposé introductif pendant
un quart d'heure 20 minutes comme vous
le souhaitez et puis n nos nos deux
rapporteurs d'abord et nos collègues
pourraient ensuite s'exprimer donc je
vous donne la parole tout de suite merci
merci c'est je vous remerci d'avoir
souhaité m'entendre et c'est c'est moi
naturellement qui me sot honoré de venir
ici plutôt me semble-t-il que que
l'inverse
euh j'ai pas voulu me dérober à cette
invitation bien que si l'on peut dire
les sont jetés et il me semble qu'il est
sans doute tard euh trop tard pour
remettre en question le projet
gouvernemental tel qu'il
est pour ma part donc je me
contenteraiis
d'expliquer ma position euh ma réflexion
les questions que je me suis posées et
qui concernait la séparation entre le
mariage et euh la adoption et à plus
forte raison les procréations assistées
et même je vais m'en tenir à quelques
aspect des questions qui me viennent à
l'esprit sans pouvoir d'ailleurs
euh déboucher si je puis dire sur des
propositions juridiques concrètes j'en
serais bien incapable donc je voulais
juste soulever quelques question sur un
problème qui est tout de même
extrêmement complexe et qui invite de
plus en en plus à à l'humilité dont j'ai
parfois
manqué la fonction traditionnelle du
mariage étant de construire
l'affiliation sur la procréation il ne
pouvait jadis concerner que les couple
homme-femme la logique de l'institution
n'était donc pas à priori adaptée au
couple de même
sexe mais le principe du mariage entre
personnes de même sexe s imposé et sans
doute pour de bonnes
raisons dans l'avenir le mariage entre
deux personnes quel que soit leur sexe
contribuera à une pleine reconnaissance
sociale de l'homosexualité il répondra à
la volonté d'un engagement affectif et
institutionnel entre deux
personnes y compris du même sexe bien
sûr mais tout ceci ne nous empêche pas
de réfléchir sur les règles générales
qui président d'autre part à
l'établissement de l'affiliation et donc
sur le principe de
l'homoparentalité notamment pour savoir
c'est une des question que je me pose si
le mot parentalité permet d'appliquer
les mêmes règles euh à tous les
enfants en effet le mariage pour tous
changera profondément l'ancienne
institution jusqu'ici donc unissant un
homme et une femme en âge de procréé le
mariage entraîit on l'a beaucoup répété
depuis le doyen carbonier le principe de
la présomption de paternité qui n'a pas
d'équivalent
féminin ce principe est encore valide
dans le cadre du mariage entre hommes et
femmes et il n'aurait évidemment pas de
sens dans le cadre d'un mariage entre
personnes de même sexe puisqu'il ne peut
pas s'appliquer tel quel à l'épouse
d'une femme ou à l'époux d'un homme
comme il est difficile de faire
disparaître du mariage en général si si
on peut dire maintenant la présomption
de paternité ce qui serait en plus assez
mal compris ou reçu par une grande
partie de nos concitoyens il faudra
préciser que ce principe de présempption
de paternité ne s'applique qu'aux époux
de sexes différents mais dans ce cas ou
bien on crée une distinction entre les
effets du mariage selon qu'il est
bisexué ou homosexué et alors on a
affaire à deux types de mariage
ou bien on applique l'idée peu sensée de
présomption parenté bien que cette idée
est été évoqué et soutenu à l'épouse
d'une femme et à l'époux d'un
homme comme si en quelque sorte le lien
matrimonial fondait
l'affiliation mais un peu comme par
magie alors que précisément
l'affiliation ne dépend plus dans la
pratique essentiellement du
mariage de fait il n'y a plus de lien
actuellement nécessaire entre mariage et
filiation légitime c'est un lien
possible mais c'est pas un lien
nécessaire les relations conjugales et
les relations parentales sont d'ors et
déjà séparables la moitié des jeunes
couples on maintenant des enfants sans
être mariés il y a plus de différence de
droit entre les enfants dit jadis
légitimes nés dans le mariage et les
enfants dit euh naturel nés hors mariage
il n'est plus interdit d'entreprendre
une recherche en en paternité même à
l'égard d'un homme marié et finalement
les enfants ont tous les mêmes droits
héréditaires de plus c'est évident mais
le le divorce ne change rien même s'il
est fréquent le divorce ne change rien
au lien de de filiation établie les
droits de l'enfant tiennent donc ou d'un
enfant tiennent donc à l'établissement
de sa filiation civile c'est-à-dire son
rattachement à chacun des parents qui
l'ont conçu et ou reconnu ou adopté que
ses parents soient mariés ou non c'est
ce qui me fait penser que la col et je
ne suis pas la seule que la colonne
vertébrale de la famille est ainsi
essentiellement l'affiliation tandis que
le mariage des parents aussi si
important soit-il pour certains devient
en quelque sorte
accessoire le couple marié paxé ou
vivant en union libre ou en concubinage
peut toujours se défaire alors que les
relations filiales sont en principe
irrévocable et justement leur force et
la sécurité juridique qu'ils donnent aux
enfants tiennent à leur permanence
indépendant des fluctuation sentimental
de leurs ascendants et des liens
matrimon éventuel qu'ils ont entre eux
cette sécurité des enfants euh qui tient
à leur filiation ne dépend donc fort
heureusement pas de l'amour ni de la
sexualité elle-même éventuellement
variable de ses
parents dans ce contexte la structure
familiale repose donc en tout premier
lieu sur l'affiliation avec la
possibilité d'ajouter aux parents un
beau parent dans une famille dite
recomposée avec éventuellement
délégation partielle de l'autorité
parentale comme cela peut se voir dans
n'importe quelle famille recomposée dans
la mesure où les couples ne sont pas
toujours stables quel que soit ce qui
les compose on peut se
demander c'est une parenthèse s'il est
vraiment dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
d'assimiler par exemple par
l'adoption le beau parent à un
parent car il n'est pas certain qu'un
beau parent s'il se sépare de son
conjoint garde exactement ou forcément
le même lien avec l'enfant du conjoint
qui lui est le parent naturel de
l'enfant c'est une simple question dans
ce contexte il convient d'interroger les
règles de
l'affiliation d'une part pour savoir sur
quoi elle repose et d'autre part pour
apprécier les effets possibles d'une
filiation établie relativement à deux
parents de même sexe par exemple à
partir de l'adoption
alors il me
semble bien que vous vous en apercevez
je ne suis pas juriste que je
m'intéresse juste au au principe qui
préside voire à la cohérence des lois il
me semble que l'affiliation n'est pas
une forme vide elle se réfère à la
réalité du rapport entre les
générations qui elle-même repose sur la
génération ou la procréation bisexué
l'affiliation symbolise et
représente l'interdépendance des sexes
dans cette transmission dans ce passage
de génération en
génération en général l'établissement de
l'affiliation dans notre droit dans
notre histoire repose
principalement sur la responsabilité de
ses auteurs sauf à l'époque du mariage
où il excluait la responsabilité pour
les enfants
illégitimes c'est
pourquoi appuyé sur cette notion de
responsabilité des auteurs de l'ENF
l'affiliation ne se fait pas de façon
symétrique mais différencié un côté
maternel et un côté paternel et selon
des règles différentes l'accouchement
pour la mère et pour le père la
reconnaissance le mariage ou
l'adoption bien sûr une mère peut aussi
être une mère adoptive mais là je parle
des règles fondamentales de
l'affiliation
naturelle je voudrais ger que la
paternité n'est pas et n'est jamais
l'équivalent masculin de la maternité
j'ai bien dit oui la paternité n'est
jamais l'équivalent masculin de la
maternité et inversement cette
dissymétrie des deux côtés possibles
sinon toujours réel de la parenté a été
gardé jusqu'ici dans les procédures
d'adoption sauf adoption par un ou une
célibataire il faudrait y revenir
jusqu'àprès donc le modèle bisexuel de
l'affiliation était resté en vigueur
appuyé sur la procréation et même
reposant sur elle c'est ce que signifie
l'acte de naissance comme son nom
l'indique cet acte inscrit à l'état
civil dans les 3 jours un enfant qui
vient de
naître la mère est celle qui on a
accouché alors que le père est celui qui
le reconnaî si c'est hors du mariage ou
bien qui est l'époux de la mère on dit
bien que l'enfant est né de ses
parents autrement dit l'affiliation
civile prend bien principalement appui
sur la procréation factuelle elle
l'enregistre elle lui donne un cadre
légal à sortie de d'obligation de
devoirs pour les parents et de droit et
cet appui de l'affiliation sur la
procréation
repose sur le principe de
responsabilité des auteurs d'un enfant
euh ce qui me fait songer d'ailleurs à
ce que dit ancionas le philosophe dans
le Principe responsabilité et il voit la
responsabilité des auteurs d'un enfant à
l'égard de leur progéniture comme une
responsabilité qui a évidemment plein
d'exceptions mais qui est
universelle dans son principe et qui est
peut-être selon lui l'archétype de la
responsabilité l'archétype être auteur
de et d'où d'où actuellement d'ailleurs
la notion de recherche par exemple en
paternité et c'est un certain paradoxe
qui mérite d'être relevé que de voir que
dans les sociétés modernes où on
pratique la procréation médicalement
assisté on a créé de toutes pièces à
travers la notion de le rôle des
donneurs anonym on a créé de toutes
pièces une irresponsabilité des des des
géniteurs des enfants puisquil ils sont
pas simplement des donneurs de
substances comme les donneurs de sang
auquel on les a comparé à l'origine mais
effectivement il donne la vie il
contribue à donner la vie pour revenir à
l'adoption c'est une procédure seconde
donc qui dépend d'un jugement et les
parents adoptifs suppl d'une certaine
manière les parents manquant soit en
remplaçant tout autre filiation dans
l'adoption pléniaire ou en pouvant
éventuellement s'ajouter à une filiation
antérieure dans l'adoption simple c'est
pourquoi sans doute dans l'avenir cette
distinction mais vous savez ça mieux que
moi entre adoption plinière et adoption
simple évidemment très très
importante mais qu'il y ait adoption par
ailleurs qu'il y ait adoption conjointe
ou adoption de l'enfant du conjoint ce
qui sont les deux enjeux de ce qui est
en question actuellement l'affiliation
légale a reproduit jusqu'ici
analogiquement la
structure traditionnelle de la
procréation c'est-à-dire une structure
asymétrique et hétérogène elle a gardé
le
schéma ce schéma ou structure qui était
celui de l'engendrement bisexuel et
c'est bien là ce qui est en question et
qui mérite d'être discuté qui peut-être
doit être transformé mais ce que je
voulais souligner c'est que ce modèle
n'est n'est ni logique ni mathématique
c'est pas 1 + 1 c'est pas 2 pour de
c'est un modèle biologique et par
conséquent
qualitatif c'est homme et femme parce
que ces deux
catégories qui n'ont de sens principal
finalement que dans la
procréation ne sont pas
interchangeable et c'est la seule raison
me semble-t-il en tout cas j'en ai pas
trouvé d'autres pour laquelle les
parents sont deux et forment un couple
qui n'est pas comme on le dit depuis 10
ans un couple
hétérosexuel qui est un couple
mixte or il faut bien reconnaître que ce
schéma serait remis en cause par
l'adoption
conjointe par deux parents de même sexe
ou par l'adoption plinière de l'enfant
du conjoint au sein d'un couple de même
sexe je je l'ai pas précisé dis tout à
l'heure mais je fais une parenthèse ce
ce genre de de réflexion de question que
je me pose n'a évidemment rien à voir
avec une idée quelconque de compétenence
ou de capacité des parents ou des
personnes à élever à aimer des enfants
ça ça ne me paraît même une question
absolument déplacée qui serait
injurieuse donc je je parle vraiment
uniquement de la question de la
structure de l'affiliation et il
faudrait laisser pour d'autres
considérations la psychologie des des
enfant mais certainement pas la capacité
des parents potentiel ou
réelle pour revenir à l'adoption de
l'enfant du conjoint il semble qu'elle a
été prévue principalement dans le cadre
du mariage classique essentiellement
pour donner un père à un enfant qui n'en
avait pas le cas inverse étant
naturellement fort rare chaque fois
qu'on étudie ces questions on retombe
sur la question de la disysymétrie de
fait entre la la dans la procréation
tion mais dans tous les cas on peut
souligner que jamais le père ou la mère
ne se remplace l'un
l'autre en revanche dans le cadre du
mariage disons homosexuel la structure
de l'affiliation change l'adoption
plinière de l'enfant du conjoint par
exemple ajoute une mère à une mère ou un
père à un père le deuxième parent de
même sexe que le premier prenant la
place du père manquant ou de la mer
manquante si on se fit à la structure
traditionnelle bien
sûr je remarquerai que les homosexuels
sont très loin de vouloir tous instituer
cette nouvelle structure ou ce nouveau
modèle comme en témoigne paradoxalement
le livre d'Éric Dubreuil qui est un peu
mal nommé de parents du même sexe parce
que en lisant ce livre je me suis aperçu
que une bonne partie plus de la moitié
des témoins homme ou femme n'étit pas
sur ce schéma je cite juste en passant
je n'ai pas pensé une seconde Dimar que
je pourrait avoir un enfant sans mère
donc il pratique une coparentalité ou
quelquefois vous avez évidemment une
bisexualité ou un partenaire qui accepte
d'être la mère ou le père ou Camille qui
refuse dit-elle le dénis de père et qui
ne veut pas je cite faire l'impasse sur
le
père donc ce vieux schéma continue ce
vieux schéma enfin ce schéma classique
continue de de
jouer la distinction le cas de
l'adoption pardon par les célibataires
qui a été semble-t-il admis après la
guerre en raison je sais plus quelle
guerre d'ailleurs sûrement c'est que la
guerre de 14 sûrement
hein admis après la Grande Guerre en
raison du grand nombre d'orphelins ne
change peut-être pas radicalement autant
qu'il y paraît le schéma dont je viens
de parler car le parent célibataire est
père ou mère il n'est pas neutre il
n'est pas
indifférent cette monoparentalité
adoptive résulte d'une situation de fait
qui est accidentelle enfant orphelin
enfant abandonnés
elle ressemble alors à celle qui résulte
d'une autre situation de faê qui est la
famille monoparentale naturelle
par exemple et le plus souvent et
massivement le cas de d'une mère
célibataire lorsque le père géniteur
soit il est inconnu soit il a pas assumé
sa responsabilité soit même il ignore
qu'il a été père cette ignorance étant
très singulière de la paternité et
indiquant bien aussi la symétrie dans la
réalité de la procréation c'est que on
peut très bien il y a plein de films
là-dessus on peut très bien ignorer
qu'on qu'on est paire alors que selon la
définition en tout cas euh fondamentale
on n'ignore pas euh que l'on est ma au
premier sens du terme cette situation de
fait donc existe précisément en raison
de la disymétrie dont je viens de de
parler mais ça ne résulte pas d'un
abandon à priori du modèle général de
l'affiliation et les deux côtés restent
possibles p et mère sans être au fond ni
équivalent ni
permutable en revanche l'adoption
pléiare de l'enfant par un couple de
même sexe ou de l'enfant du conjoint
institue quelque chose de très nouveau
qu'on a appelé
l'homoparentalité
c'est-à-dire un schéma qui remplace le
vieux schéma par celui de deux parents
de même sexe en ce sens il me semble que
ceci créerait ou crée un nouveau régime
de filiation et donc un double régime de
filiation l'un qui repose ou
continuerait de reposer sur la
procréation et sur sa structure et
l'autre qui reposerait plus
essentiellement c'est ce que disent en
tout cas beaucoup
de de des théoriciens de
l'homoparentalité qui reposera
essentiellement sur la
volonté et sur la volonté de deux
personnes de même sexe qui veulent
construire en quelque sorte un couple
parental qui ne comprennent pas pour ne
pas dire
exclus le parent de l'autre sexe même si
dans les faits il il il est nécessaire
de recourir à des
suppléants
anonyme par exemple dans le cadre de la
PMA pour
euh donner naissance à à
l'enfant un projet donc de ce de ce type
d'omoparentalité posera j'ai pas le
temps de l'aborder maintenant je vais
juste aborder mon dernier point posera
évidemment dans l'avenir la question du
rôle de la médecine procréative et du
rôle de l'assistance médicale à la
procréation qui jusqu'à présent était
inscrite dans la thérapie de
l'infertilité et qui dans le cas de
l'homoparentalité évidemment prendrait
un tout autre un tout autre statut et
répondrait à une toute autre
exigence un autre modèle en tout cas sur
ce nouveau principe de filiation ce sera
mon dernier point sur ce nouveau
principe de filiation euh je note que la
ministre de la Famille madame bertinoti
parle aujourd'hui de filiation
homosexuelle et de filiation
hétérosexuelle et non plus de filiation
paternelle et maternelle on parle aussi
depuis un certain temps de parents
lesbiens et de parents gu et non plus de
la
corrélation père mère ou paternité
maternité comme le montre ce langage le
couple Père-Mère est donc remplacé par
le couple homosexuel de hommes deux
femmes ce n'est plus le sexe qui fait le
parent père ou mère c'est la sexualité
c'est une question que j'avais posé il y
a déjà pas mal pas mal de temps en en
travaillant sur la théorie des des
genres et en voyant que c'était ça la
proposition de la théorie des des
genres c'est pourquoi donc si ce n'est
plus le sexe qui fait le
parent mais la sexualité ça voudrait
dire qu'on est mer en fonction sa sa
sexualité et non pas parce qu'on est une
femme et c'est
pourquoi cette conception conduit par
ricochet à définir sans arrêt
aujourd'hui le couple parental masculin
féminin comme hétérosexuel et non pas
comme mixte la question se pose alors de
savoir si dans le droit civil la
sexualité peut ou doit remplacer le sexe
et Sion ne serait pas conduit
euh alors à définir des hommes des or la
personne au moins la personne des
parents en fonction de son orientation
sexuelle et non plus en fonction de son
sexe ça pose des questions finalement
assez
profondes ce ne serait plus les hommes
et des femmes mais des homosexuels et
des hétérosexuels qui seraient parents
des homoparents et ou des hétéroparents
or on peut constater que beaucoup
d'homosexuels qui ont eu des enfants
dans leur vie avec un ou une partenaire
de l'autre sexe ne se sont jamais pensés
comme homoparents ils étaient des hommes
pères ou des et la sexualité il me
semble vient s'ajouter euh au sexe la
diversité des sexualités qui peut même
changer pendant la vie ça se voit c'est
ce qui fait que des des des gens ont pu
avoir des enfants dans une Prem dans un
premier moment de leur vie et puis en
changeant alors ils ont ses enfants et
puis ils forment éventuellement un un un
couple homosexuel donc la notion de être
au mot parents pose tout de même des
questions à la fois psychologiques et
juridiques assez complexe en tout cas le
mariage tout seul ne conduit pas à cette
à nécessairement à ces nouvelles
catégories et identification puisque il
suffit de parler dans ce cas d'union de
deux personnes quel que soit leur sexe
alors que le principe de
l'homoparentalité conduit et son langage
constant le montre à cette
division il me semble au contraire c'est
le sens de ma réflexion par ailleurs euh
sur les sexes et les genres il me semble
que l'orientation sexuelle ne supprime
pas et n'abolit pas la distinction de
sexe sauf évidemment si on tend à
instaurer euh et à et à considérer comme
une sorte de fondement la théorie cuir
du du genre à savoir remplacer euh
l'identification de sexe par
l'identification sexuelle il me semble
ainsi que la
parentale introduit un conflit entre
deux régimes ou deux fondements de son
de l'établissement de l'affiliation la
procréation d'une part avec sa structure
non symétrique pour l'affiliation et la
volonté valable maintenant pour les deux
sexes remarque pour finir sur les
conséquences et les attendus de cette ce
fondement sur la
volonté la construction de la par é sur
la volonté elle s'inspire me semble-t-il
de deux modèles le premier modèle c'est
la paternité traditionnelle qui pour une
part est évidemment volontaire la notion
de reconnaissance et elle s'inspire
d'autre part de la notion de parent de
parent d'intention construite en
Californie par un
jugement de la Cour à propos d'un
conflit engendré par une maternité pour
autrui et c'est la notion de parents
intentionnelle a été créée à ce propos
les deux parents ayons fait appel à une
mère porteuse le père ayant euh été le
le géniteur euh de l'enfant la mère
avait peut-être donné ses ovocyes et
ayant fait appel à une mère porteuse à
la suite du conflit la Cour a appelé
parents intentionnels euh les parents
qui avaient fait recours à la mère
porteuse si bien que il m'a semblé que
cette notion de parents intentionnel ass
assez original
finalement n'était pas antérieur à au
problème de la PMA ou de la GPA mais
était bel et bien une conséquence et que
lorsqu'on invoque cette notion de de
parents intentionnel on est déjà pris
d'une certaine manière dans cette
logique et cette construction
biotechnologique euh la construction de
la parenté sur la volonté donc je disais
est inspiré aussi par le modèle masculin
de la procréation et de l'affiliation je
ne sais pas si on pourrait dire ça mais
la paternité est un titre alors que
traditionnellement la maternité à
travers la grossesse et l'accouchement
renvoie à un un un état d'une certaine
manière et à un fait c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs dans le
droit je fais beaucoup de raccourcis
vous m'en excuserez mais une femme si je
ne me trompe pas ne peut pas pas
reconnaître l'enfant porté et mis au
monde par une autre mais seulement
l'adopter peut dire comme
ça l'adoption plinière par une
femme de l'enfant de son épouse ferait
ainsi coexister deux
maternités deux maternités entièrement
légitimes et plinières d'une certaine
façon et par conséquent elle détacherait
la maternité de l'accouchement c'est une
conséquence importante me semble-t-il
par rapport au droit tel qu'il est
établi
actuellement ce détachement de la
maternité de l'accouchement est
d'ailleurs l'objet récurrent d'une
demande explicite des partisans de
l'homoparentalité ça fait longtemps que
la question a a été posée or ce qui me
paraît inquiétant dans
cette demande dans ce dans ce
détachement de la maternité de de
l'accouchement c'est que il pourrait
secondairement ouvrir la voix à l'usage
de mère
porteuse pour les couplle mixte aussi
bien que pour les couples
gay le minimum de prudence serait
peut-être alors de garder pour
l'affiliation de tous les enfants le
principe selon lequel principe minimal
père et mère ne sont pas
interchangeables mais al effectivement
euh on peut plus accumuler les pères et
les mères on peut simplement additionner
des parents plus des parents qui peuvent
être des parents par adoption simple
plus des beaux parents avec
éventuellement des délégation d'autorité
parentale ce qui mettrait à égalité
toutes les familles
recomposées donc de ne pas confondre les
parents et les beaux-parents et aussi de
limiter dans certains cas l'adoption de
l'enfant du conjoint au moins à sa forme
simple et non plainère je m'arrête là
parce que je crois que j'ai été un petit
peu trop longue merci jeoulez
oui je voulais vous remercier très
sincèrement madame Sylviane
akasansski pour votre exposé qui est
d'une grande clarté parce que nous
entendons beaucoup d'exposés moi je dois
dire que nous
comprenons très bien même si nous ne
sommes pas des spécialistes de
philosophie ou de droit ou de
psychanalyse nous sommes simplement des
législateurs mais c'est déjà beaucoup
donc c'est très agréable de bien
comprendre votre pensée du moins
j'espère que nous avons compris c'est ce
que nous allons voir immédiatement
donnant la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur Jean-Pierre Michel Mo je vais
être très bref je partage ce que ce que
dit Jean-Pierre suur et et je constate
madameazenski que votre pensée a évolué
disons depuis une quinzaine d'années
notamment sur le couple ensuite sur
l'affiliation
moins mais la maternité aujourd'hui elle
est déjà détachée de l'accouchement
puisque la gestation pour autruie existe
elle est interdite en France bon elle
est permise ailleurs dans des pays qui
ne sont pas exotiques comme la
Grande-Bretagne ou la Belgique par
exemple regrette bon et donc elle se
pratique bon elle se pratique
illégalement mais elle se pratique
d'autre part on sait très bien qu'il
existe actuellement des
expériences je ne sais pas si elles se
font sur les humains mais je je pense
que si peut-être pas en France
de maternité extrauté
oui qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
exactement sans accouchement en dehors
du corps en dehors du corps c'est-à-dire
par utérus artificielle oui dans
un dans une couveuse dans une boîte je
sais pas non ça ça j'ai posé la question
à plusieurs médecins à plusieurs
scientifiques on me dit non c'est c'est
pour l'instant en tout cas pour
peut-être vous pouvez souhaiter ça sou
pas non mais Henry Atlant a écrit
là-dessus un un livre intéressant euh
sur pardon je peux vous peux euh sur
l'utérus artificiel en disant peut-être
dans 50 ans ce serait concevable euh
beaucoup de scientifiques disent que non
dans la mesure où l'échange entre
l'embryon euh et et et le le corps de la
mère est justement un échange avec le
corps total avec toutes les hormones
avec le cerveau avec le système enfin un
ensemble des échange qui passe par le
cordon ombilical qui est tellement
complexe et qui engage tellement la
totalité de la vie de la mère que
l'utérus n'est évidemment pas juste une
poche avec quelque chose dedans qui
permet à l'embryon de se développer donc
je je scientifiquement on on ne voit pas
d'ailleurs on voit que un un embryon mis
dans une dans un
contexte comment dire dans dans un
milieu artificiel ne peut jamais ni pour
les animaux ni pour les humains on n pas
essayé sur les humains ni ni pour les
mammifères en tout cas ne peut jamais se
développer au-delà je crois de quelques
jours ou quelques semaines et on ne peut
pas plus bon euh de de de même les
couveuses par exemple ne peuvent
fonctionner que si l'enfant a déjà
atteint c'est vrai qu'on a fait des
progrès fabuleux dans ce domaine mais il
faut qu'il a atteint au moins 6 mois ou
quelque chose 5 mois et demi quelque
chose 5 mois et demi quelque chose comme
ça en tout cas écoutez ça nous ça nous
éloigne d'un monde à la hxley euh
qui n'est pas toujours très convivial
enfin mais ça c'est une une parenthèse
tout à fait personnelle que je me
permets de faire mon questionnement est
je crois que Michel Menier le rejoindra
c'est pour dire oui parce que je vois
les questions qu'elle pose ou les
interrogations qu'elle a c'est que il y
a aujourd'hui des réalités alors on peut
on peut être pour on peut être contre
mais elles sont là euh si le législateur
ne fait
rien ces réalités seront encore plus
extravagantes qu'elles ne le sont
aujourd'hui et illégales
sur la GPA par exemple on ne parlait que
de ça qui bon qui pour l'instant n'est
pas pour demain peut-être on voit
qu'aujourd'hui en France des mères
portent pour leurs filles qui est
absolument bon je crois que c'est le
pire de tout bon donc ça paraît
rarissime he mais il paraît que ça
existe j'ai connu le cas il y a un très
bon documentaire qui a été fait dans les
années 80 sur le cas de de sœur et qui
laisse assez perplexe et qui est assez
émouvant mais il est évident que ça se
pass d'ailleurs dans une ferme dans une
campagne française où l'une des deux
sœurs ayant déjà deux enfants avait dans
la plus grande
discrétion donner un enfant si je puis
dire d'ailleurs à à sa sœur
et c'était effectivement très très
émouvant et c'était la garantie absolue
de la non mararchandisation puisque
c'était pour la sœur et dans un commeun
accord mais si on réfléchit d'un point
de vue du point de vue de la loi et si
on se dit la loi devrait-elle cadrer ça
à quoi on aboutit on aboutit à l'idée
que on va instaurer le principe en
quelque sorte qu'une sœur peut faire un
enfant pour sa sœur et que donc on va
placer les sœurs en général je je résume
en situation d'être légalement celle qui
va pouvoir dire oui ou non à la demande
d'enfant de sa sœur dans les
circonstances où la sœur n'a pas
d'utérus ou chose ne peut pas peut pas
enfanter c'est c'est énorme c'est énorme
surtout si l'on sait que il s'agit à ce
moment-là d'une sorte d'inceste du
second type comme dit François hritier
la loi peut pas encadrer ça pas non plus
encore moins enfin pas ni plus ni moins
pour une mère et et sa fille que ça
arrive et que ce soit de l'ordre du fait
c'est une chose que ce fait puisse être
institué par la loi avec les
conséquences de
légitimation que ça implique et de
demande interrelationnelle c'est c'est
une toute autre question si la loi
suivait toujours ce qui se produit alors
ça aait des conséquences bien bien
inquiétantes mais je je laisse cette
question de de de de la famille si vous
voulez je vous remercie de cette parole
je je me permets de dire juste un mot je
suis en effet tout à fait d'accord avec
vous parce que on entend beaucoup
l'argument
suivant il y a une réalité qui existe en
France ou une réalité qui existe
ailleurs dans tel ou tel pays et même il
y a une législation qui existe ailleurs
dans tel ou tel pays par conséquent les
choses étendent ainsi on ne peut que
légiférer par rapport à la situation qui
existe moi je dis que si c'est ça si on
suit je ne je ne partage absolument pas
cet argument qui est pourtant récurrent
parce que dans ce cas il faut fermer
cette maison parce qu'il suffirait qu'il
y ait une loi qu'il y ait une réalité
quelque part
ou qu'il y ait une loi quelque part pour
qu'elle s'applique de rechef au
législateur que nous sommes nous sommes
là pour statuer sur la loi française par
rapport au principes qui qui sont les
nôtres ou que nous allons définir mais
il ne peut pas y avoir des choses qui
s'imposent de telle manière puisque
c'est comme ça il faut légiférer dans ce
cas il faut fermer l'établissement et je
trouve que ce serait fâcheux excuse-moi
excusez-moi tous parce que j'ai tort
sauf que sauf que la loi peut interdire
certaines choses bien sûr elle peut
interdire certaines choses je je suis un
peu inquiète parce que vous je peux non
je vous laisse
pe demander ce qu'on va faire parce
qu'on a un problème
d'horaire ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va donner la parole à Madame Michel
Menier rapporteur et aussi à celles et
ceux qui vont vouir le prendre dans la
salle et si vous êtes d'accord vous
pourriez faire une réponse globale je
crois que c'est mieux ainsi parce que
sinon on va engendrer des frustra
d'accord il ne faut jamais je vois que
Madame prince me soutient madame Menier
vous avez la parole oui merci monsieur
le Président donc très rapidement parce
que Madame
agazenski A a dit des choses ben prenant
en compte l'évolution des familles en
fin de compte hein puisque vous nous
avez parlé des familles recomposées des
familles
monoparentales des oui des familles
adoptives bien sûr et puis des familles
homoarental parce que elles existent
déjà les enfants autour de nous on en
connaît vivent avec de femmes ou vivent
avec deux hommes grandissent et parfois
d'ailleurs maintenant sont presque
adultes eux même s d'ailleurs vous
employez le mot vivre comme synonyme de
famille bah ils vivent dans leur famille
ils sont ét éduqués et élevés dans la
leur famille la recomposition c'est pas
de l'homote parentalité intrinsèquement
c'est ils ont deux parents qui s'aiment
et deux parents qui qui s'aime de
parents du même sexe euh donc voilà donc
ça on en connaît et je pense que
beaucoup ici donc moi j'entends bien
tout ce que tout ce que vous dites mais
alors justement pour prendre en compte
ce fait et pour faire en sorte que tous
les enfants soient
euh oui comme à égalité et et sécurisé
de la même manière qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire
sur le cadre de loi qui pourrait venir
en réponse si ce n'est pas par le
mariage et l'adoption de l'enfant du
conjoint quelle pourrait être l'issue
pour que il y ait égalité entre tous les
enfants ici dans notre République bien
merci Michel Meier qui souhaite la
parole monsieur deè
oui il y a un argument qui qui revient
souvent effectivement s'il
SIME moi je ne suis pas un fin juriste
mais je suis mare de ma commune il
m'arrive de célébrer des mariages je
n'ai vu nulle part dans le Code civil ni
dans les articles que nous lisons le
jour du mariage civil une référence à
l'amour et donc je je voudrais avoir la
vie de quelquesin ici au fond si
l'argument c'est l'amour ne faut pas-il
ne faut-il pas envisager euh un
dispositif demandant à l'officier d'état
civil de vérifier la réalité de l'amour
et par conséquent monsieur le rapporteur
que diriez-vous d'un
amendement qui
proposerait que l'officier d'état civil
puisse vérifier la matérialité de cet
amour oui merci Monsieur delège le
Conseil constitutionnel ayant demandé
que la loi soit intelligible il faudrait
déjà que vous proposiez une définition
de l'amour mais je pense que vous y
parviendrez alors maintenant qui veut la
parole personne ne veut dire quelques
mots madame Gillot non madame Benbassa
vous n'avez rien à dire ça m'étonne de
vous monsieur
darnich non
Madame Nicole
Bonnefoi oui madame Blondin madame
Génisson et Madame ben comme ça tous
ceux qui qui regardent la télévision
verront que vous êtes là voez c'est
important c'est c'est
sympathique mais non mais non c'est moi
qui prends l'entière responsabilité de
mes propos hein mais je vous remercie
d'être d'être si fidèle à c'est à ces
travaux parce que c'est quand même de
très des dizaines d'heures de d'audition
auxquelles nous nous procédons bien
alors je crois madame Sylviane
agasensski que d'abord nos deux
rapportes on parl avec éloquence c'est
la vérité que Monsieur monsieur deè
également que votre propos initial était
tellement lumineux et